أرقام هو وثلاث جنرات معه بعملية لم يسبقها أي شيء
حتى في الجزائر، اللي هي فكرة المعتقلات
جاؤوا بخطة جنونية وشريرة
يهجّروا كل السكان المدنيين، حتى يخنقوا المقاومة
1929 هجّروهم، ماتوا ناس في الطريق
خاصة الأطفال وكبار السن
أخيرًا قررت أعمل الحلقة الأخيرة
وهي قلت: أبغى أروح أزور المعتقلات الخمسة، معتقلات الموت
فرجعت لبنغازي، وأنا والله يا عبدالرحمن، لا أُبالغ
كنت أرتعش ومذعور من الرعب، شفت الموت، عيني عينك
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية، وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
هذه الحلقة جزء من مشروع فهم، وشرح الوطن العربي
أزعم أن هذا، وفهم التاريخ الاجتماعي والسياسي والثقافي
يقربنا إلى بعض أكثر
زائد أنه يوضح مدى التقارب والتقاطعات
لسكان الدول العربيّة من المحيط إلى الخليج
هذه الحلقة عن ليبيا، الدولة اللي بالكاد نعرف عنها شيء
غير «القذافي» و«عمر المختار»
واللي في هذه الحلقة
اكتشفت أن «ليبيا» الاسم هذا، هو جديد
استحدثته إيطاليا في عهد الاستعمار
في هذه الحلقة نبغى نعرف، ما هي التركيبة السكانية لليبيا
علاقتها بالدولة العُثمانيّة، وبجيرانها
وكيف كانت بداية الاستعمار الإيطالي لها
يقول ضيفي، بعد أن بحث الموضوع لأكثر من خمسة عشر سنة
أن الإيطاليين قاموا بإبادات جماعية ومعتقلات
كانت هي التمهيد لما حصل لليهود في ألمانيا
يقول: اكتشفت أن الألمان لم يعجبوا بتجربة استعمارية
مثل تجربة المعتقلات الإيطالية في ليبيا
الحلقة دسمة، والضيف مليء ومتمكن، وباحث رصين في الشأن الليبي
صرف حياته كلها في فهم ما حدث في ليبيا
الدكتور علي أحميدة، أستاذ ورئيس قسم العلوم السياسية
بجامعة «نيو إنقلاند» الأمريكيّة
الحلقة تاريخيّة وعلميّة ومهمّة ومؤثّرة
وفيها الكثير من المعلومات والمصادر والمراجع المهمة
اللي ذُكرت في هذه الحلقة
إن كنت مهتمًا
ستجد المعلومات والروابط موجودة في نشرة فنجان البريديّة
الرابط في وصف الحلقة، أما الآن لنبدأ
شدني حلقتين مميزتين، حلقة الأستاذ التونسي
«فوزي»
وكان مليء، كأنه يبغى يعطي اللي ما عنده قبل لا يغادر
والدكتور «جورج صليبة»
هذا أستاذ عظيم وعالم كبير، والحلقة كانت ثرية جدًّا
أنا ما جاءتني فرصة أشوف البقية
لكن واضح أنك غاوي الموضوع
الحمد لله
وبعدين في صديق ليبي، عمل معي مقابلة
«طارق»
«طارق» إيوة، قلت له: شو قصة هذا الأخ السعودي؟
لأن السعوديين أعرفهم كثير، لأن زملائي كانوا وإخواني في الدراسة
وقال لي: هذا بدأ قبلي، وهذا الآن بالنسبة للعرب
مش بالجزيرة بس، وللعرب، عنده ملايين الملايين
فكويس، ما شاء الله، شيء جميل جدًّا
أنا عندي مشروع، أعتقد أنه مرّة مهم جدًّا، في غاية الأهميّة
وهو فهم بعضنا البعض
فكثير من الدول العربيّة، نعتقد أننا نعرفها
صحيح
وفي الأخير نكتشف أن احنا ما نعرف الكثير
هذا كلام صحيح 100% والعكس صحيح
العرب الآخرين ما يعرفوا السعودية
قطعًا، كُل العرب لبعض، ما يعرفوا بعض
عندهم تصورات عامّة
قد تكون صحيحة، وقد تكون خاطئة تمامًا
وفهمنا لبعض يقرّبنا من بعض
بالتأكيد، هذا لا جدال فيها
وفيه عدم معرفة الناس لبعضها
وفي أحيانًا شيء عجيب، كثير الناس يصرّوا على آرائهم
مع أن ما يعرفوا شيء
ويصرّوا على أن والله، هذا صفته ونعته يعني
صحيح
لكن أنت كيف وجدتني، يا عبدالرحمن؟
أنا مختفي شوية عن العرب الآخرين
صحيح، والله أنت مختفي جدًّا، مو شوية
لكنني، أقول لك: هذا المشروع مهم بالنسبة لنا
فعملنا حلقة عن السودان
ممتاز الأخ «غسان» وكان لبق
جدًّا
وكانت حلقته مشوّقة، وما قعّر كثير في التفاصيل
كانت كثير مفيدة
ممتازة ورائعة جدًّا، وعلى ذلك فقِس
فكانت مهم بالنسبة لي، مثلًا برضو عندنا ليبيا
والمغرب وتونس والجزائر وبقية الدول
وليبيا من الدول البعيدة عن فهمنا
مش غير بس، يمكن أكثر الدول العربيّة مجهولة
فعلًا، حتى أنت ذكرت في وحدة من
أن العرب يعرفون مثلًا الاستعمار لفلسطين، وهذا معلوم مثلًا
وعندك الجزائر برضو كذلك
بس الاستعمار اللي حصل لليبيا
يكاد أن ما أحد يعرف عنه أبدًّا أي شيء
لا
فتجد معلومات مهمة، كلما نعرفه عن ليبيا يمكن «القذافي»
«الكتاب الأخضر»
«القذافي» والملك «إدريس»
وغرائبيّته شوية، أشهر من النار على العلم
لكن هي يمكن العرب
أنا أتفق معك، العرب لا يعرفوا بعضهم
ولكن ليبيا ما زالت مجهولة أكثر، جدًّا
ليش تتوقع الجزائر حظيت بهذا الانتشار
والاستعمار حاضر في ذهن العرب بينما ليبيا غائبة؟
هذا سؤال وجيه يا عبدالرحمن، الجزائر، الحركة الثورية
عندهم موجات من المقاومة
المقاومة الأولى، الأمير «عبدالقادر»
و«المقراني» فيما بعد، والمقاومات الأخرى
هُزمت، وهاجر القيادات بما فيهم الأمير «عبدالقادر» وأسرته
وأتباعه إلى دمشق
وعاشوا، وما زالوا كثير منهم في دمشق
دمشق كانت من الأماكن المعروفة
أنا أعتقد
وفي نفس السياق، لما هُزمت المقاومة الليبيّة
اللي استمرت عشرين سنة
وحُطّمت الجمهوريّة الطرابلسيّة
اللي هي من أوائل الجمهوريات في الغرب الليبي
وفي العالم العربي كله
هاجروا منهم ناس إلى دمشق
وناس هاجروا عندكم في السعودية
الملك «عبدالعزيز»
كانوا كثيرين من القيادات الليبيّة
وجدوا ملجأ عنده، مثل السّيد «بشير السعداوي»
السّيد «صالح القارقني» و«نوري»
القائد الليبي العسكري «طارق الأفريقي»
اللي هو كان من أوائل رؤساء أركان الجيش السعودي
هذا كان من قيادات المقاومة، والجهات في ليبيا
أنا أعتقد الإجابة
لأن الحركة الثورية، ما نسميه احنا الثورة الجزائرية
اللي بدأ الإعداد لها في نهاية الخمسينيات
وبدأت في مثلًا ثورة، في المدن والأرياف
ضد الاستعمار الإيطالي
وكان زخمها في الإعلام والراديو والجرائد والتلفزيون
فرنسا تقصد؟
ضد الاستعمار الفرنسي في الجزائر
فأصبحت قضية الجزائر
في الخمسينيات والستينيات هي قضية العرب
فهذا يبدو، أنا اجتهادي هذا
هذا خلّى أن احنا العرب بدأنا نطلّع عليها أكثر
صارت قضية الجزائر هي قضية العرب الأولى
ليست قضية الجزائريين فحسب
صحيح
وصعود الحركة المُعادية لاستعمار القومية «عبدالناصر»
والحركات الاستقلالية في فترة زَهوها واندفاعها
فالجزائر كانت تمثّل، مثل فلسطين
القضية هي ليست فلسطين بس
تمثّل الشجون، وتم تبنيها كأنها قضية العرب كلهم والمسلمين
ولكن المقاومة الليبيّة هُزمت عسكريًّا، للأسف الشديد، في 1931
وكانت في تلك، الأجيال الأولى كانت تفهم القضية الليبيّة
وخاصة في الصحافة العربيّة
سواءً في مصر، وللا بلاد الشام، وللا العراق
مثلًا الحج اكشفنا أنه كان مؤتمر إسلامي، ليس ديني فحسب
ولكن كانوا المجاهدين يحتكّوا بالمسلمين الآخرين في الحج
وكانوا يقوموا بالدّعاية وبالتثقيف في المسألة هذه
القضية الليبيّة بعد هزيمتها خفتت، وكأنها نُسيت
لأن جاءت قضية فلسطين
وتقسيم فلسطين، والاحتلال الصهيوني لفلسطين تاريخيًّا
وبعدها جاء الانفجار الجزائري
فأنا اجتهادي أن في هذه الفترة، يا عبدالرحمن
القضية الجزائرية والفلسطينية صارا رمز للقضايا العربيّة بشكل عام
رغم أن «عمر المختار» حاضر في ذهن الناس كُلهم
صحيح، لكن هذا حصل في فترة من الفترات
أنه هو رمز النضال العربي والإسلامي ضد الاستعمار
وصحيح، شيخ الشهداء «عمر المختار»
مات متواضعًا، ورفض أنه يشترى
وهو شيخ مُسن، ومات وهو واقف
ووقفته هذه صارت رمز للنضال الأخلاقي والوطني
ضد الهيمنة والاستعمار والإمبريالية في هذيك الفترة
لكن أعتقد بالنسبة للأجيال الشابة
فلم «مصطفى العقّاد» هو اللي خلّى القضية أكثر
باجتهادي، هو اللي خلّى العرب تعرفوا
ليبيا هذه كانت فيها مسألة وحشية وصعبة ومهمة جدًّا
وعرّفتهم بدموية هذه التجربة
والوقوف النضالي لشعب صغير وفقير وحافي
ولكن بسبب صُموده وتنظيمه وعقيدته الإسلامية في تلك الفترة
استطاع أنه هو يقاوم لمدة عشرين سنة
وأدّت في نهاية الأمر، حسب تقديري
إذا كان الجزائر ماتوا فيها مليون ونص
في ليبيا، قد تُدهش يا أخ عبدالرحمن، أن حسب تقديري
ما بين ثلث إلى نصف الشعب الليبي مات خلال الأربعين سنة
من هذا الاستعمار الدموي
أعطيك مثال، حسب الإحصاءات العُثمانيّة بـ 1908-1910
تعداد «تونس» كان مليون، وليبيا كان بين مليون، ومليون ونص
في 1943 تعداد تونس صار مليونين ونص
ليبيا تقريبًا، بذاك الوقت، يكون مليون. وين راحوا؟
الناس كانوا يتزوجوا، وينجبوا أطفال وكذا
لكن وين راحوا؟ هذا السؤال اللي ما أحد جاوب عنه
هذا يقود إلى، ليش القضية الليبيّة صارت للآن مجهولة؟
فلم «عمر المختار» كان مهم
أنا أعتقد «مصطفى العقاد» مهما قيل عنه
هو قدّم رؤية عربيّة إسلامية
لرمز من رموز النضال ضد الاستعمار
وخلّى آلاف، بل ملايين من الشباب العربي والمسلم، والشابّات
يتعرفوا على جزء دموي، مهم، ونضالي على القضية الليبيّة
الطليان الموسوليني والفاشيين
كان في تخطيطهم أن يعتبروا ليبيا «الشاطئ الرابع»
اسمها هذاك الوقت، ما كان في اسم «ليبيا» يا عبدالرحمن
ما في اسم ليبيا؟
«ليبيا» اسم روماني وقديم
في قبائل «ليبو» أصلية، وفي قبائل محلية أصلية، قبل مجيء العرب
مع الفتوحات؟
مع الفتوحات، وبعدين عُرّبت شمال أفريقيا في فترة
احنا نسميها «الهجرة الهلاية»
قبائل «بني سليم» و«بني هلال»
اللي هو تقريبًا نحو 500 ألف في بعض التقديرات، 200 ألف
اللي هم في النظرة النمطية يقولون: كالجراد، ضربوا كل شيء
وأنا أعتقد هذه أنا تحديت هذه النظرة، مغرضة جدًّا
اللي صار أنهم عرّبوا شمال أفريقيا، لقرون استمر التعريب
وعندك المكوّن الأصلي اللي هو «الأمازيغ»
اللي احنا في الأول يسمّوهم العرب، هم يفضلوا اسم «الأمازيغ»
هذا هم السكان الأصليين
وعملية، كانت في حرب في الأول
ولكن بعدين دخول الإسلام له تفسيرات كثيرة مهمة جدًّا
وفي قبائل عربيّة تبربرت، أو صارت أمازيغية
ومعظم «الأمازيغ» تعرّبوا
أو على الأقل صاروا يتكلموا اللغة العربيّة
واللغة «الأمازيغية» في البيت
فالتركيبة فيها حيوية وتعقيد غير عادي
الآن في مقولات أُخرى تأتي على مسألة الإثنية والأقليات
أنا لا أؤمن بها، وأعتقد أنها هرطقة وكلام فارغ
وتُستغل، وتُبالغ فيها كثيرًا
من حق المجموعات الثقافية أن تعبّر عن لغاتها وتراثها
ونعترف بالتنوّع العام، لأنه مهم
العرب لازم يفهموا هذه، بما فيهم الليبيين
لكن قضية الأقليات، أنا مضايقتني كثير
كيف؟
مفهوم الأقلية هو مفهوم أوربي
احنا عندنا في التاريخ الإسلامي والعربي، المِلل والنحل
وتاريخيًّا الإسلام أو التجربة العُثمانيّة
كانت بكل التناقضات اللي فيها
كانت تعترف بوجود «المسيحيين» و«اليهود» والأقليات الأخرى
وبذلك تناول الموضوع من الناحية العملية
مهم أن ننتقد الاضطهاد
اللي مبني على ضد اللغات والتقاليد والثقافات وغيره
لكن المفهوم الحديث، الأقلية
ينطلق من منطلقات الأوربية والغربية
بمعنى «اليهود» أقلية تاريخيّة معروفة بكل مقاييسها
وفي الأخير اضطهدت
«الغجر» نفس العملية
احنا عندنا مطالب مشروعة
لكن التّداخل العربي بالأمازيغي بالطارقي وحتى التوباوي
لأنهم أقلية نحو 40 أو 50 ألف، شوية
لكن الآن بعد سقوط نظام القذافي
صاروا كلهم، يقولوا لهم: أنتم أقليات
فيوظف مفهوم الأقلية لأغراض أخرى
وأنا أعتقد لا بد من التمييز بين الاثنين
المطالب المشروعة الثقافية واللغوية
والنظر إلى الأمازيغ أنهم هم السكان الأصليين
هؤلاء أصلًا العرب اللي في شمال أفريقيا
وبذلك احترامهم مشكلة أقلية، لكن فهمهم من هذا السياق
أنت عشت في ليبيا إلى أن تخرّجت من الثانوية، صح؟
أنا خلفيتي، صحيح، غريبة شوية يا عبدالرحمن
درست في جنوب ليبيا في مدينة سبها، وهي عاصمة إقليم فزّان
ومحافظة سبها فيما بعد
درست في ودان حتى الثالث ابتدائي
وبعدين الوالد انتقل لسبها، عاصمة فزان
ودرست فيها الابتدائي والإعدادي والثانوي
كان في نظام جميل في العهد الملكي
وفي عهد القذافي، حتى السبعينيات استمر
اللي هي أوائل الطلبة يُرسلوا للدراسة برة، بمُنحة
فأرسلونا، بدل ما يرسلوني إلى أمريكا، وللا أوربا
الظاهر أن وزير التعليم في ذلك الوقت مع القذافي
قال لهم: أي حاجة في مصر، ابعثوهم لمصر
فبعثونا لكلية الاقتصاد والعلوم السياسية في القاهرة
أنا درست في القاهرة لمدة أربع سنوات
بعدها رجعت ليبيا قليلًا لفترة قصيرة جدًّا
ومنها جتني منحة للدراسة، فدرست في مدينة سياتل اللغة
ودرست الماجستير والدكتوراة
المنحة في الأخير، للأسف مريت بظروف صعبة
لأن قُطِعت المنحة، الابتعاث بحجج واهية
أني لست ثوريًّا في النظام
فقعدت ثلاث سنوات، وأنا أشتغل، وأدرس
أدرس كنت باللغة العربيّة للأمريكان
وأساعد بعض الزملاء باللغة الإنقليزية، لغاية ما خلصت
بعدما أنهيت الدراسة في جامعة واشنطن
نشرت كتابي بعد سنة، وهذا فتح لي آفاق
والأستاذ المشرف كان دائمًا يُصر علي
يقول لي: علي انتظر شوية، ليبيا لن تختفي
العالم العربي لن يختفي، شو رأيك تقعد كم من سنة؟
عشان تعمّق دراساتك، وتأخذ خبرة في التدريس؟
وبيني وبينك، أنا كنت متضايق من النظام
لأن كثير من أصدقائي وإخواني
خاصة كُتّاب وأدباء أصدقاء وقريبين لي
وأنا كنت ناشط في الحركة الطلابية، سُجنوا لمدة عشر سنوات
فصارت حتى من الناحية الشخصية
ليبيا صار بعكس ما كنت أتوقع
أني ممكن أرجع، وأصير أستاذ في ليبيا
تغير البرنامج، فصرت أقول لأمي، الله يرحمها
كانت تقول لي: علي أنا ولدتك، وأنت تركتني بعد الثانوي، وين رحت؟
فأقول لها: يا أمي العام الجاي، ولقيت الحياة
قدمت على شغل ثابت يسمّوه «تنير» في النظام الأمريكي
ووفّقت، حصّلت شغل كويس، وبعدين صرت «تينيرد»
وصرت أستاذ كرسي، ورئيس قسم
وجتني فرصة، يا عبدالرحمن، لم أخطط لها بكل أمانة
وهي فرصة أني أتعمّق في البحث العلمي، وأتعلم التدريس الحديث
التدريس ليس بمعنى أن الواحد يدرس بس
طريقة حديثة لتتعامل مع الطلاب، وتأخذ خبرة عميقة، وتطور أدواتك
بعد الأمور تسهّلت شوية في ليبيا، صرت أزور كل عام
وأحيانًا تجيني دعوة لجنوب أفريقيا ولمصر وفي الأمم المتحدة
زي ما رحت البحرين، أول مرّة في زيارتي للخليج
ومؤتمرات في أوربا ولبنان وتونس
فجتني فرصة، أني ممكن مشروعي المعرفي يمكن يخدم
الأشياء اللي تهمني في ليبيا والعالم العربي
بوجودي في أمريكا أكثر
ففجأة صرت
أقول: أن الحياة مرات تخليك تأخذ قرار من غير أنت ما تدري
وما كان صار عندي
مسألة أن والله أنا راح أندمج، وأدوب في هذا المجتمع الكبير وغيره
ما كان عندي هذاك الرهاب أو الخوف الشديد
قلت: أرض الله واسعة، والواحد طالما أنه هو مستقل في تفكيره
وينتج، ويصل أقصى درجات طموحاته المعرفية
فكان وجودي في أمريكا شيء إيجابي كثير
برغم كل كل الإشكاليات المطروحة
فالكتب باختصار، الكتاب الأول والثاني
والثالث اللي هو الكتاب الأخضر، اللي صدر من نحو سنة
أنا بجيها بس ودّي أعرف، أولادك كلهم مولودين في أمريكا؟
إي، أنا عندي اثنين، وقط
يهمني الاثنين، القط غير مهم
يمكن أنا أختلف معك، يا عبدالرحمن
لما الولاد كبروا، القط والله حنيّن ولطيف
كيف علاقتهم بالهوية الليبيّة؟
هل انسلخوا؟
هذا سؤال حلو جدًّا
أنا عندي بنت سميتها حنين
الناس يقولوا لي: والله حنين للوطن؟
قلت لهم: لا، هو حنين لأشياء مهمّة
ابنتي الآن تدرس في الماجستير في جامعة لندن
قالت لي: بابا، كيف تسمّيني حنين؟
قلت لها: يا بنتي، وهي حطتني في المحك
قلت لها: يا بنتي، أنا لما أتفكرك، أنسى الحنين
لكن معليش أنا سميتك اسم غريب شوية
وابني زكريا، اللي هو وُلد بعدها بسنتين، وهو
ربّيتهم، كان إشكال كبير، لكن ما حاولت أني
حاولت أربيهم أنهم يكونوا عندهم
إلمام ومعرفة بأنهم مسلمين، وعرب أمريكيين
ولكن وُلد في هذا البلد، وأركّز على الأشياء الأساسية
ولكن خليتهم يكونوا منفتحين
وعندهم الخيارات ليتعمّقوا فيها كما يحبون أم لا
ودرت في أشياء، راح تضحك عليها شوي عبدالرحمن
لكن لا أُمانع أقول لك عليها
مثلّا: قبل لا يناموا كنت عم أعمل شيئين، أغني لهم بالعربي
أيش تغني لهم؟
أغني لهم أغاني ليبية بسيطة، وللا أغاني مصرية
مثلًا: يا صباح الخير ياللي معانا
وللا ابني زكريا بحب أغنية «على البساطة البساطة»
وترجمتها له، وبعدين أقرأ لهم الفاتحة
وهم صغيرين، كانوا يقرؤوا الفاتحة كويس
فابنتي الآن، قالت لي: ياريت تعمّقت لي أكثر
قلت لها: أنا أعطيتك الأساسيات
لكن الآن أنت مصرة تتعمقي بأدواتك وطريقتك أكثر
يتكلموا العربيّة؟
حنين بنتي تتكلم العربيّة، جبت لهم مدرسين من البداية
كانوا في أساتذة يدرّسوا اللغة العربيّة في جامعتي
فأجيبهم للبيت، أعمل لهم غَدوة حلوة، أكل ليبي حلو
وأخليهم يدرّسوا الأولاد، وهم صغيرين
بعدين شجّعتهم في الثانوي والجامعة، يأخذوا دورات باللغة العربيّة
في أشياء بسيطة ممكن تتحكّم فيها
زوجتي أمريكية، رغم أنها أسلمت
لكن مسكينة، عربيتها مكسّرة
الأشياء اللي أنا أحبها، الموسيقى
درست الموسيقى ست سنوات في ليبيا
وبذلك أحط لهم الموسيقى العربيّة في السيارة والبيت
وكان الأمل أروح أزور ليبيا كل سنة، لكن الظروف الصعبة السياسية
خلّت المسألة معقّدة شوية، للأسف الشديد
فكيف تشوف علاقتهم بليبيا؟
هل يعرّفون أنفسهم بليبيين؟
والله هم يقولوا: احنا الاثنين
قلت لهم: شيء جميل
أنتم تشوفوا نفسكم ليبيين وأمريكيين وعرب ومسلمين
لكن يقولوا لي: احنا نبغى نأخذ الجميل في الاثنين
قلت لهم: أنا لن أفرض عليكم
لكن حنين لغتها العربيّة، أخذت بالجامعة قرأت النحو والصرف
وقالت لي: معقّد جدًّا
قلت لها: حتى احنا متعقدين منه
ياريت يدورون لنا حل المبدعين، ومدرسي اللغة العربيّة والضليعين فيها
أن يبسطوا قواعدنا شوية ويخلّوا، وللا يعطونا وصفة سحرية عليها
قلت لها: احنا اللي نشأنا كعرب، معقّد لنا
لكن قلت لها: اصبري شوية
الآن تكتب وتتكلّم ممتاز، مجرد تحتاج تدريب أكثر
زكريا، للأسف لغته مكسرة شوية
لكن يحاول أنه يحتال عليّ بالكلام. مرّة يقول لي كلمة هنا
يقول: بسم الله أو السلام عليكم، وللا كذا
يُزعجك هذا الموضوع؟
في الأول كان يزعجني
لكن بعدين قلت: أنا أعمل اللي علي، وربنا يوفقهم
لن أضع ذنب عليهم، ولا علي
أنا هذا كان ودّي أعرف إذا أبغى أقول: شخص ليبي
من هو الليبي؟
سؤال صعب جدًّا الإجابة عليه، كل واحد راح يجاوبه بصورة
لكن أنا عندي إجابة يمكن متواضعة أكثر، وما هي متقعرة
هي الإحساس
هم يعرفوا مدى ارتباطي بليبيا
ولكن أنا تربّيت في، بالنسبة لي أنا شخصيًّا لما يسألوني
تربيت في بيئة عربيّة إسلاميّة
مش بالصورة اللي هي الآن، الإسلام السياسي
وللا الشعارات، والهويّاتية، وللا إطلاق اللّحي، وللا غيره
لا، احنا أهلنا وناسنا اللي ربّونا، أبهاتنا وأمّهات وجدّاتنا
أنه هم هذا جزء من تركيبتهم، بشكل عام
وأقول لهم على أشياء أخرى، الليبي، هذه من ناحية الدين هو الأساس
اللي هو أن احنا مسلمين
ولكن كيف الواحد يقول أنا مسلم، هذه تختلف من شخص إلى آخر
أنا أعتقد التجربة العربيّة الإسلامية مهمّة
والتجربة مرتبطة بكيان جغرافي، وأكثر تحديدًا، يا عبدالرحمن
أقول أيش نأكل ونلبس، والموسيقى اللي نستمع لها
كيف نتعامل مع الآخرين، ومع بعضنا، ومع الغرباء
والدي، الله يرحمه، كان في رمضان مرّة سألوني عنه
كان في رمضان على الإفطار يأخذ اللبن والتمر
ويذهب إلى المسجد في الحي
والبيت دائمًا يجيب معه الغرباء
لبنانيين ومصريين وتوانسة وآخرين يجوا البيت
وكان عمره ما فرض علينا مسألة
لكن يقول احنا العقيدة أهم شيء
وحُب المعرفة مهم جدًّا، ولكن كانت أجمل ما في الوالد، الله يرحمه
كان ممارساته وتعامله، مش أيش اعملوا كذا وللا كذا
أعتقد لما أتكلم على ليبيا، بالنسبة لي أنا تجربتي، مركّبة
لأني عشت طول حياتي برّة
في ناس قالوا لي: غريبة أنك ما زلت تتكلم عربي
قلت لهم: صحيح، لكن أهلي غسلوا دماغي
والظاهر كتبوا لي مكتوب وللا شيء
كان غسيل طيّب
إي، أنا بالنسبة لي الهوية هي مسألة ليست ساكنة، يا عبدالرحمن
عشان أضيف لك نقطة أخرى، وليست جامدة، متغيّرة
ولكن مرتبطة بالمكان، وبالمؤسسات، وبالحياة اليوميّة
وأنا شخصيًّا بالنسبة لي، اللي بقى منها الآن
وأنا الآن صرت كَهِل، هي الذكريات والأهل والأصدقاء والمكان
ولكن لا يعني الهوية أنك تقعد في السعودية أو في ليبيا
تعملها أينما تذهب
وأنا أعتقد ديننا وقرآننا فيه جوانب كثير حلوة
أرض الله واسعة، هذا مفهوم جميل جدًّا
صديقي العزيزي الأستاذ «إبراهيم الكوني»
هو جنوبي مثل حالتي
يقول لي: يا على الوطن يسكننا أينما كنّا، وأينما نذهب
وهذا صحيح
فيمكن يا عبدالرحمن، أنا مرّات أقول لنفسي
نحتاج أن نستمتع ونقدّر، ونثّمن الحياة اليوميّة
احنا عندنا غناء ثقافي واجتماعي ومعرفي
وعندنا الصراعات والإحباطات مثلما الشعوب الأُخرى
الشعب الأمريكي، الآن جيراني وزملائي وزميلاتي
اكتشفت أن عندهم مشاكل الدنيا، ومُحبطين وزعلانين
وعندهم انكسارات واكتئاب، وعندهم كل شيء
مرّات احنا العرب نجلد ذاتنا، ونشعر بدونيّة كثير
وكأن ما لم ننجز هذا الشيء أو هذا، معناه احنا متخلّفين
أنا بالنسبة لي الآن، الأمور أكثر
صحيح، جميل الإنسان يكون طموح
ويواجهه الفساد والتهميش والإقصاء والصراعات
الصراع مثلًا الآن في فلسطين، هذا ما زال قضيتنا الكُبرى
البشاعة والعنصريّة، النظام الصهيوني الآن اللي بيحاول
وأدعياؤه والمدافعون عنه، بيحاولوا أنهم يبرّروه، وللا يخلّوه نظام عادي
هذا شيء غير مقبول
الفساد اللي صاير في المنطقة في الأنظمة العربيّة
العنف اللي صاير هذا مهم
لكن مرّات، قلت لزميل لي، مغربي
قلت له: أنا لا أبغى أن العرب يغيروا طريقتهم
أحيانًا اللي هي عاطفيّة ووجدانيّة وكذا، هذا ما يميّزهم
وطريقة ضحكهم ومبالغتهم وتعاملهم، هذا جزء حيوي فيها
لكن أعتقد أن هذه الجوانب اللي هي في الحياة اليوميّة
مهم نستوعبها ونستمتع بها، ونأخذ لحظات من الحياة
اللي هي فيها الكثير من السعادة والتقدير، بدل مُحاربة طواحين الهواء
أو خلق أشياء يمكن هي مش احنا
لهذا أنا دائمًا لا أركّز على الدولة
العرب لحد الآن، يقول لك: الدولة وبناؤها، والدولة الحديثة وغيره
أنا بالنسبة لي هذا أنا أعتقد مبالغ فيه، لازم نركّز على المجتمعات
ومجتمعات ليست بشكل عاطفي، وللا سطحي، وللا
نحكي على بنية التعليم الجيد والجمال وتمكين الناس، والتعرف عليها
وأن احنا صحيح نحو اثنين وعشرين دولة، وهذه باقة
وعندنا تعدّد جهوي، حتى من أيّام الإسلام
لكن في نفس الوقت، في عندنا عُرى ووشائج تخلينا نقول:
أنتم في السعودية، واحنا من ليبيا
زي ما اكتشفنا لما كنا مع بعضنا في سياتل
اكتشفنا أن زملاءنا وزميلتنا عندنا أشياء تتجاوز الحدود
احنا مسلمين وعرب، وتربطنا علاقات قويّة تتجاوز كل الأشياء هذه
وأنا أعتقد هذا يمكن اللي نركّز عليه في المستقبل
وبجانب الجوانب الناقصة والإحباطات والهزائم والفساد والقمع
والإقصاء وغيره، وفرص العمل
أن نبدأ نركّز على الجوانب الثقافية، والأشياء اللي تجمعنا
ويا ريت نبدأ نتعرف على بعضنا بشكل أكثر عُمقًا وجديةً
هذا يمكن يخلينا حتى مسألة أن احنا متخلفين
احنا مش عارف أيش، احنا العرب..
أو موضوع، وأنا لا أحبه إطلاقًا، اللي هي جلد الذات
والشعور بالدونيّة
وأعتقد أن هذا يحتاج لإعادة تفكير، والتقييم
أتفق، أتذكر قبل شوي كنت تقول أن أنت من «الأشراف»
نعم
ودّي أعرف أيش المكونات
سواءً الثقافية، وللا القبلية الموجودة في ليبيا؟
في «الأشراف» و«الأمازيغ»
عبدالرحمن، في تنوع زي ما عندكم في السعودية متنوعة ومتعددة
ليبيا على صُغرها، عدد سكانها نحو 7 مليون
لكن جغرافيًّا رابع دولة من ناحية المساحة في إفريقيا
ليبيا قارّة كبيرة
وأعتقد من الناحية الجغرافيّة متعددة
عندنا منطقة مثلًا في الجبل الأخضر، زي عندكم في عَسير
في جبال وخضرة وأشجار وغيره
ومنطقة رأس الهلال، وللا شحات
وللا المدينة الرائعة، درنة، من أجمل المدن العربيّة برأيي
على البحر والجبل الأخضر
وعندنا صحراء شاسعة نحو 90% أو أكثر منها
من الصحراء الكبرى في ليبيا
عندنا المنطقة الغربيّة الأكثر كثافة
من الناحية الثقافية والإثنية في تعدد
ولكن في، مش بشكل كبير، غالبية الليبيين، يا عبدالرحمن
هم سُنيّون مالكيّون، وشوي عندنا إباضيين
في الجبل الغربي وزوارة
لكن الغالبية العُظمى مش بس سُنّة، مالكيي المذهب
والشيء العجيب أن المذهب المالكي
هو المذهب المهيمن في شمال إفريقيا
منطقة المغرب العربي الإسلامي، هو غالبية سكانه مالكيي المذهب
حتى الصعيد المصري، على فكرة يا عبدالرحمن، هو مالكي
لأن عندهم الأحناف والشوافع، وعنده تعدديّة في الدلتا
وفي القاهرة وكذا
لكن الصعيد المصري مالكي المذهب، وهذا مهم جدًّا
تركيب السؤال، في هناك مُدن وبوادي
وتاريخيًّا، بحكم الجغرافيا والبيئة دائمًا الباحثين الغربيين
وحتى العرب الآن يحكوا على مثلًا التنظيم القبلي في ليبيا
وأنا دائمًا أتأفّف من هذا الموضوع
ليه؟
لأن القبيلة مكوّن تاريخي، صحيح
لكن يُنظر للقبيلة كأنها مفهوم سُكوني جامد
تسألهم، ما الفرق بين القبيلة
في بداية القرن العشرين، والواحد والعشرين؟
هل المَشاع القبلي واحد؟
هل الملكية ما زالت كما هي؟
هل عملية التحضّر والهجرة للمدن، لها تأثير أم لا؟
هل التعليم له دور، وللا لا؟
هل التراتبات الطبقية، والفئوية من ناحية الثروة، لها تأثير أم لا؟
هل اقتصاديّات السوق لها دور، وللا لا؟
هل القبيلة مفهومها واحد؟
هناك قبائل تجاريّة أو شبه رُحّل أو رُحّل
الآن الشعب الليبي يعيش في خمس مُدن كبيرة، 80%
ولكن لا يستطيعوا الإجابة على هذا
راح تصير المسألة، المجتمع الليبي هو مجتمع قبلي
هم بدو شمال أفريقيا، ودائمًا يشبهونا بكم
بترول وعندهم بادية، وما هم متحضرين كثير
وأنا أعتقد هذا كلام غير علمي
وللأسف الشديد الآن بعد 2011، لأن هناك جهل رهيب
لا أقول في العالم العربي خاصة، إلى حد ما
لكن الباحثين الغربيين كلهم من المهووسين بقضية القبيلة
كمفهوم غير تاريخي، ولهذا أنا دائمًا لا أحب هذا اللفظ
وفي الكتاب الأول، حاولت أرسم التركيبة الاجتماعيّة والاقتصادية
المكون القبلي والصفوف، وهناك قبائل تجاريّة، ليس لها
هناك قبائل شوية رُحّل، مُعظهم يمارسوا في الزراعة والترحال
وبعد الاستعمار الإيطالي، ضُربت التركيبة العشائرية المشاعية للقبيلة
أيش أصبحت؟
أصبحت مستقرة في اقتصاد السوق الاستعماري الرأس مالي
والهجرة للمُدن؛ للعمل
واقتصاديات السوق، استمرت بعد الاستقلال
والدولة الريعيّة أدّت إلى توطين معظم القبائل
وصارت التركيبة أكثر تعقيدًا من مسألة أن القبيلة
لأن الناس يقولوا: أنا أصلي مثلًا دوسري، وللا زهراني
وللا حوتي، وللا غيره
الليبيين يقولوا، كما في السعودية، والعالم العربي
فيما يسألوا عن تقليد ثقافي
أن اسمك الأخير يكون إما اسم القبيلة أو العائلة أو البلدة اللي وُلدت فيها
عسيري مثلًا عندكم كثير في السعودية
دوسري وشهراني وعنزي وشمّري
احنا يقول لك: والله في النهاية
يقول: «الشريف علي عبد اللطيف أحميدة الشريف»
أو يقول لك: «معمر محمد منيار القذافي» القذاذفة
وللا «منير البرعصي» البراعصة
لكن لا يعني أن القذاذفة والبراعصة والأشراف
من الناحية الاقتصادية والاجتماعيّة
هم ما زالوا كما كانوا 50-60 سنة فاتت
ولهذا أنا أعتقد من الناحية العلمية، هذا هرطقة
وكلام غير علمي، وغير دقيق
أنت تقول مثلًا
رموز الجهاد الليبي، هم الآباء المؤسسين للهوية الليبية الحديثة
إي
ودّي أعرف، أيش الهوية الليبية الحديثة؟
وأيش أثر الآباء المؤسسين، ومن تقصد بهم؟
هل هم «عمر المختار» والمجاهدين هذول؟
عندما جاءت الإمبرياليّة الغربية، والاستعمار الإيطالي تحديدًا
جاؤوا غزوا ليبيا في أكتوبر 1911
تقريبًا نحو 35-40 ألف جندي، وبوارج عسكريّة
المجتمع، ليبيا كانت ولاية عُثمانيّة
مثل العراق ومصر وبلاد الشام وفلسطين وتونس
والجزائر حتى 1830
كانوا جزء من الدولة العليا العُثمانيّة، أو الإمبراطورية
وعندكم الحجاز، وجزء من اليمن
بقية العالم العربي، المغرب، السلطنة العَلَويّة
أو الجزيرة العربيّة تحت التكوين المحلّي
اللي هو الدولة السعودية
اللي بُنيت على مؤسسات، ونموذج محلي إسلامي
أو الإمامة في اليمن
مؤسسة بُنيت من خلال التقاليد المحليّة الإسلامية العربيّة في اليمن
فأعتقد المقاومة، أنا أعود إليك للإجابة على سؤالك
لما سألتهم، أنتم
أتذكر قلت لأمي، أنتِ منو يا حجة «مبروكة»؟
قالت لي: علي أيش فيك، أيش مشكلتك؟
قالت لي: أنا ليبية وعربية ومسلمة
أنا أعتقد مرات أن سؤال الهوية نخبوي
من وجهة نظري، قد أكون مخطئ فيه يا عبدالرحمن
أنا أعتقد الناس العاديين عارفين هم مَن
لكن النخب مرات تختلق في هذه القضايا
لأغراض، وممكن دوافع آنيّة لا تُفصح عنها، بالنسبة لها مهمة
للأسف الشديد، حركات الإسلام السياسي ضخّم مسألة الهوية أكثر
وعلى أساس أنهم صاروا هم حُجّاب
والمتكلمين على قضية الهوية عندنا
في ليبيا، أعود لك إلى إجابة الناس اللي قاوموا الاستعمار
ومركز الجهات في طرابلس، وهذا مهم جدًّا في العالم العربي
المركز الوحيد اللي جمّع نحو لا يقل عن 20 ألف أو أكثر
رواية شفهية من الأحياء
فهم قالوا: احنا جاهدنا، وقاومنا الاستعمار من أجل الله والوطن
أنا أعتقد هذا أعطانا مفتاح
لكن، ما هي المؤسسات؟
ما هي الأيديولوجيات اللي طرحوها لتوضيح مَن هم؟
وأنا وجدت ثلاثة نماذج، معليش أنا نطول عليك شوية
لنعطيك السياق العام
حتى لا تكون الإجابة إما أبيض أو أسود أو بسرعة
عندنا في حركة تجديديّة إصلاحيّة عبقريّة
اسمها الحركة السنوسيّة، أسّسها عالم جزائري
اسمه «محمد بن علي السنوسي»
في منتصف القرن التاسع عشر، دَرس في مستغانم
ودرس في جامعة القرويين، في شمال إفريقيا عندنا
اللي تعرفوها أنتم أكثر يمكن في المشرق العربي
والجزيرة العربيّة، والأزهر
لكن في جامعتين أُخريات
اللي جامعة الزيتونة في تونس، وجامعة القرويين
هذه الجامعات اللي هي
أنا برأيي يجب أن تحظى كثير من الاهتمام لأنها مهمة جدًّا
العجيب أن النخب المحلية في المدارس الفرنسية أو الزيتونة أو القرويين
النخب في تونس والجزائر والمغرب نفس المسألة
والليبيين كثير كانوا يدرس فيها أبناؤهم
يرسلوهم إما للزيتونة أو الأزهر
الحركة السنوسيّة باختصار، لأن هذا موضوع غَني ومهم
هذا العالم الكبير اللي أنا أعتبره من كبار العقول الفذّة
في القرن التاسع عشر، المُصلحة
درس في القرويين، وبعدها مَر بالأزهر
ولكن عُلماء الأزهر لم يرتاحوا له كثيرًا
وذهب إلى الحجاز، لماذا؟
لأن كان أستاذه الكبير اللي هو «أحمد بن إدريس الفاسي»
هذا أستاذ فذ، ومن تحت منه طلعت الحركة المرغنية والسنوسيّة
والحركة الإدريسيّة
كان أستاذ قطب، ولم يؤسس حركة، رفض أن يؤسس حركة أو طريقة
هذا العالِم «محمد بن علي السنوسي»
ذهب مع أستاذه للحجاز، ومن الحجاز إلى اليمن
وتلامذته الأدارسة اللي في عسير
بعض منهم اللي هم كانوا في عسير والسودان ومصر
فالمهم بالنسبة للسنوسية، ماذا حدث؟
حتى نضبط الموضوع، وما نخليه يضيع منا
أولًا كَتب كِتاب ينتقد فيه إغلاق باب الاجتهاد
ويدعوا إلى إعادة باب الاجتهاد
واضح أنه هو مش بس عالم دين ومجدد
عنده فكرة أنه بكوّن حركة اجتماعيّة
مبنية على التقاليد الإسلاميّة
التقاليد المالكيّة والصوفيّة والمؤسسات الزاوية
وركّز على شيئين، يا عبدالرحمن
الاكتفاء والاعتماد الذاتي على الذات
والتجارة وتنظيمها، والتعليم
وكانوا أتباعُه من جميع أنحاء العالم الإسلامي بما فيهم المدينة
من عسير واليمن ومصر والسودان والمغرب وتونس والجزائر
الإخوان، وحتى الأتباع يُسمى الإخوان
واستطاعت هذه الحركة
لأنه وجد في ليبيا بعيدة عن عُيون الدولة العُثمانيّة
فجعل الصحراء الليبية، شرق ليبيا في البيضاء
الزاوية الأولى، وبدأ يكوّن في الزوايا
ومنها بدأت حركة أو طريقة متقدّمة جدًّا
أنا برأيي كانت حديثة
واستطاع أنه ينظّم التجارة والقضاء والتعليم والتنظيم الإداري
وكوّن معهد عالي في واحة مجهولة اسمها «الجموم»
هذه الحركة، لأنه وُلد في الجزائر، ولم يستطيع العودة لها
بدأت في التكوين والإعداد التنظيمي
الشيخ «عمر المختار» وحتى آتي إلى الإجابة هُنا
هو أحد تلامذة هذه الحركة، وتعلم في زواياها ومعاهدها
ولهذا عندما جاء الطليان غزو ليبيا 1911
واجهتهم مقاومة مُجتمع منظّم
وكانت كل قبيلة تُعطي متطوعين، وزادهم وأكلهم وبنادقهم
ولما يستشهد أحد، يُبَدلون بمُتطوعين آخرين
ولهذا الطليان استمرت المقاومة ضد مجتمع
ليس القيادة فحسب، لمدة عشرين سنة
بالنسبة لغرب ليبيا
كانت التركيبة السكانية مُركبة
هناك تعداد أكبر، ثلثين سكان ليبيا في الغرب الليبي
ومدينة طرابلس هي المدينة الأكثر هيمنة
من الناحية الاقتصادية والإدارية والبنوك والمعاملات والإدارة
والقضاء والتعليم وغيرهم
والقيادات في المنطقة الغربية جاؤوا بفكرة كثير رائعة
وهي تكوين جمهوريّة
كوّنوا جمهوريّة، سمّوها الجمهوريّة الطرابلسيّة
ولم يتفقوا على قيادة واحدة
فكوّنوا قيادة جماعيّة من أربع قيادات
الطليان بعثوا رسائل إلى القادة الغربيين والعالم الإسلامي
بالاعتراف فيها
لم يرد أيًّا من القادة الغربيين والأمريكيين على رسائلهم
وكان عندهم مجلس الشورى ومفتي، ويا سيدي، جيش
وكان عندهم نظام إداري، وكانت في رؤية متقدمة جدًّا
الطليان دمّروا عسكريًّا هذه الجمهورية الوليدة
خلال سنتين
فكنت بسألك، ليش سقطت بهذه السرعة، هل لضعفها؟
لأن القيادات كانت بينها توازن، ولكن بينها خلافات
واستطاعوا أنهم عسكريًّا يضربوهم ضربة قاسمة
واستغلوا بعض قيادات ضد بعضها
عملية تلاعب بالقيادات، وشراء بعضها
لكن عسكريًّا جاؤوا بجيش قوي جدًّا
واستخدموا الطيارة، أول مرّة في ليبيا في التاريخ الحديث
واستخدموا الطيران لملاحقة المجاهدين
وفيما بعد الغاز السّام، لأول مرّة في 1929
كان دائمًا المقاومة ترجع إلى التخوم، وإلى الدواخن في فزان
لكن القيادات الغربية في المنطقة الغربية
وأنا أعزوها إلى تعقيد التركيبة الاجتماعيّة
والصراع بين الزعامات السياسية
«رمضان» و«المريض» و«عبدالنبي بالخير»
والزعيم الكبير «سليمان الباروني» من أصل أمازيغي
ولكن قائد كبير، وهاجر لعُمان، لأنه إباضي
وأصبح مستشار لسلطان عُمان
كما صار بعض المهاجرين الليبيين بعد الهزيمة
مستشارين للملك «عبد العزيز السعود» وعاشوا في السعودية
وآخرين اشتغلوا في سوريا ولبنان
فاللي صار أن، ليش الجمهورية الطرابلسيّة والحركة السنوسية مهمّات؟
لأن هي
بالنسبة للحركة السنوسيّة
هي قامت على أنها حركة اجتماعيّة، وللا دينيّة؟
الاثنتين مع بعضهن
وكان في هدف تأسيس دولة؟
أنا قلت في هذا الكتاب الأول في أطروحتي الأولى
قلت: أنه لم يعلن الدولة، ولكن البُنية التحتية
والمؤسسات اللي خلقوها، والتركيز على هذه
التجديد في هذه، واستخدام المؤسسات المحلية
هو أدّى إلى قيام دولة، من غير ما يعلنوها
لأن خايفين لو أعلنوها، الطليان كانوا راح يدمروهم
ولكن من الناحية الرمزيّة والمؤسسيّة
بعد استشهاد شيخ الشهداء «عمر المختار»
وقتل، ونفي آلاف من الناس اللي كانوا في المقاومة
بما فيهم جدي، الاثنين، جدي لوالدي ووالدتي كانوا في المقاومة
وهذا يمكن سِر اهتمامي أنا بهذا التاريخ تحديدًا من البداية
المؤسسات السنوسيّة، أعطت زي ما تقول
التشيع أو الأصول المحلية لدولة الاستقلال فيما بعد
الجمهورية الطرابلسيّة أعطتنا نموذج آخر للمقاومة
وعندما هُزمت الفاشية الإيطالية في 1943
لأنهم تحالفوا مع هتلر والنازية في ألمانيا
بدأت لعبة المنفيين الليبيين
سواءً في دمشق أو القاهرة أو تونس
وخاصة الجناح اللي كان في دمشق
كانوا على درجة عالية من الثقافة والتعليم والكفاءة
فبدأوا في تعبئة الرأي العام، بما فيها استخدام الحج
اكتشفت أن الحج مثلًا كانوا يوزعوا في منشوراتهم
ويلقوا في خُطب، وبتعاطف السلطات في الحجاز
وفيما بعد الملك «عبد العزيز» ذيك الفترة
بعدها الموضوع مباشرةً
ولكن في نهاية الأمر، يا عبدالرحمن
لما هُزمت الجمهورية الطرابلسيّة
مؤتمر غريان، قرّر يقبلوا بأن بايعوا منذ بداية العشرينيات
أن يكون أمير مسلم يقود الاستقلال ضد الطليان
لأن الليبيين وحّدتهم شيئين
الجهاد من أجل حق تقرير المصير ضد الاستعمار الإيطالي
وفيما بعد، مسألة، أعتقد بعد الاستقلال
مسألة المسابقة القانونية والاجتماعيّة والتنمية
السؤال الوطني العام والسؤال الاجتماعي
لكن اختلفوا في أشياء كثيرة
وبذلك أعطوا البيعة، الحركة السنوسيّة لما ضُرب فيها
الجناح العسكري والمقاوم، وآلاف ماتوا
بما فيها، الكتاب الأخير وهو عن المعتقلات
وراح نأتي إليه قليلًا، أتمنى هذا
لكن بدأ السّيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
اللي هو حفيد السّيد «محمد بن علي السنوسي»
الفكرة هنا لازم نكون واعيين أن الحركة السنوسيّة لم تكن «شوفينية»
مثلًا من ناحية أنه لازم يكون ليبي، وإلا
لا، أتباعها من جميع أنحاء العالم الإسلامي
وقامت بدور تعليمي وتنويري في نشر الإسلام بطريقة بديعة
في غرب، مثلًا في تشاد وغرب السودان
وفي شمال نيجيريا والنيجر
أنا أعطيك مثال بسيط، أنا دائمًا أُحب هذه الأشياء العملية
مثلًا اسم السنوسي تجده
في شمال تشاد والنيجر، وجزء من غرب السودان
وفي ليبيا، حتى الغرب الليبي
والحركة السنوسيّة انتشرت بشكل عميق
في الشرق، والجنوب الليبي، وفي تخوم المنطقة الغربية
لأن الدولة العُثمانيّة كانت قوية بمؤسساتها
فلن تتغلغل في جوانب مُدن الحضارية في الغرب الليبي
كيف كانت علاقة الحركة السنوسيّة مع الدولة العُثمانيّة؟
شائكة ومُتغيّرة
الدولة العُثمانيّة كانت تنظر بعين الريبة
وتحاول أن تسيطر على الشرق الليبي
ولكن من الناحية العملية السّيد «محمد بن علي السنوسي»
اختار تخوم ودواخل شرق ليبيا
لأن الدولة العثمانيّة ليست لها قوية هناك، ونُفوذ كبير
وعندما صارت قوية، صار في نوع من التفاوت، أُعفوا من الضرائب
الزوايا السنوسيّة أو المساجد، زي ما تسموها أنتوا
احنا نسميها زوايا في شمال إفريقيا
اللي هي أعفيت من الضرائب العُثمانيّة
ولكن كان هناك نوع من التوتر
وكان هناك مبعوثين عُثمانيين إلى الكُفرة، العاصمة الثانية
وفيما بعد في عاصمة ثالثة في تشاد
لأن رؤيتها إسلاميّة، الجامعة الإسلاميّة بشكل عام
فاللي صار أن الدولة العُثمانيّة، كانت علاقتها، أنا باعتقادي
مبنيّة على التهادُن فترة، ولكن التوتر فترة أُخرى
وعندما هُزمت، وجاء الاستعمار الإيطالي بدأ التحالف
ما بين الحركة السنوسيّة والدولة العُثمانيّة
لأنه واجهوا عدو واحد
ولهذا الزعيم الثالث للحركة السنوسيّة
وهو دُفن في البقيع، عندكم في الحجاز
شخصيّة عظيمة ومناضلة
اسمه السيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي»
ابن السّيد «المهدي السنوسي»
اللي هو ابن المؤسس الإمام «محمد بن علي السنوسي»
ليش أعلن عن وجود الدولة السنوسيّة في 1913؟
أيش السبب بعد هذا كلّه؟
هي بدأت في منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
لأن أعتقد كانت أولًا
أيش الحاجة لإعلان دولة آنذلك؟
هل كانت لجمع الناس في مقاومة ضد الاحتلال الإيطالي؟
المقاومة جمعت المسألة، وبعدين لأن معظم الشيوخ والمجاهدين
جاؤوا ليس من القبائل، اللي زي ما تقول، المرموقة أو العُليا
من قبائل المرابطين والجَماعات الأخرى
وصار في نوع من التمازج بين الاثنين
على الكفاءة والقدرة العسكرية والمعرفية
وبذلك كان لما هُزمت الحركة السنوسيّة
«عمر المختار» شيخ الشهداء، أُسر وحُوكم وشُنق
استشهد، أمام الناس، الـ 20 ألف
في نفس الوقت الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
بعدما هادنوه الطليان، وأعطوه إمارة، وصار أمير
واعترفوا بالدولة السنوسيّة
جاؤوا الفاشيين الطليان، بقيادة موسوليني
وقالوا: لا مُعاهدات، ولا قانون أساسي، ولا حكم ذاتي، ولا يحزنون
ليبيا هذه لنا هذه جزء من إيطاليا، كما كانت أيّام الحكم الروماني
استغلّوا المسألة هذه، فبدأوا عملية بشعة وعنيفة ودمويّة
لضرب آخر جيوب المقاومة
هذا كان برضو من قبل وفاة أو مقتل؟
نعم، لكن الفاشيين جاؤوا بعنف، وجيوش أكثر تسليحًا وعددًا
واضطر السّيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي» يُهاجر إلى مصر
وهنا صارت في نوع من التباين في وجهات النظر
الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي» قال: لا بد من التفاوض
والاعتراف بأن الوضع الآن صعب، ولكن أيضًا إيجاد حليف آخر
والإنقليز، كان يهمهم أن يكون أمنهم في مصر مضمون
لأن يخافوا من توتر الجبهة الغربية
فكانوا يحتاجوا إلى...
وخاصة أن السّيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي»
اضطر بضغط عُثماني
أنه يهجم على مصر أيّام الحرب العالميّة الأولى
وانتصر في البداية، وانضم له بعض الضّباط المصريين
واحتل جزء من الواحات والمنطقة الحدودية
ولكن الجيش الإنقليزي ضرب بعنف، وهُزم
فصار يقود جيش جائع، وانتهى به أنه هو
الطليان والإنقليز فرضوا في المفاوضات، أنه يُطرد من ليبيا
فهو هجم على مصر باسم الجيش الليبي؟
لا، كان بالتحالف العُثماني
العُثمانين كانوا «أنور باشا»
مصرّيين أنها لازم يكون في الجيش العُثماني من فلسطين
والقوات العثمانيّة والسنوسيّة
تُهاجم على الوجود الإنقليزي في مصر
هذه كانت رُؤاهم العسكرية، فَشل
واللي صار أن السّيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي» طُرد من ليبيا
وأعطوه الحق أنه يذهب إلى المنفى
فذهب بغواصة ألمانيّة إلى إسطنبول
ورُحب به كثيرًا، وكأحد قادة الجهاد الإسلامي
ولكن هذيك الفترة، الحلفاء بدأوا في الإعداد لغزو تركيا
و«تركيا الفتاة» لم يعجبهم كثيرًا هذه الشخصية الكاريزمية القوية
فاضطر بهدوء أن يهاجر، وذهب إلى الحجاز
وعاش في الحجاز، حتى وفاته في عام 1933
ودُفن في الحجاز
الملك «محمد إدريس السنوسي» رحمة الله عليه
بعد وفاته في مصر، طلب أن يُدفن في الحجاز
فشوف يا عبدالرحمن، كيف تداخل العالم الإسلامي
برغم الدولة الحديثة وكل شيء، لكن هناك أشياء متداخلة
قطعًا
أنا لم أكمل الإجابة على سؤالك
اللي صار أن بعد الهزيمة العسكريّة
بعد عشرين سنة من المقاومة
السّيد «أحمد الشريف» انتهى بالمنفى في الحجاز، وتوفى فيها
الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي» كان مَنفي في القاهرة
كان موجود في مصر
وكان وجهة نظر السّيد «إدريس السنوسي»
لا بد من التفاوض، ويكون عندك حليف
وكانت جزء مهم منها، كان الإشكال بالتأكيد
وكانت الجماعات في الغرب الليبي
في فزان كان في شخصيّة كاريزميّة، عائلة أولاد «سيف النصر»
هذول كانوا من قادة الجهات، وكانوا سنوسي المذهب
وفي الغرب الليبي، كانوا القادة الجمهوريين اللي حكينا عليهم
واللي كثير منهم انتهوا في المنفى في مصر
وفي السعودية ولبنان وسوريا ومصر وتونس
فصار التفاوت، جاء تاريخ عطاء المجتمع الليبي
فرصة ذهبية لم يتوقعها أحد
هزيمة الفاشيّة الإيطالية مع الألمان في الحرب العالمية الثانية
في حُروب العالمين، وما تبعها في غزو الحُلفاء إلى أوربا
فبدأ التفاوض في المنفى، وداخل ليبيا على الاستقلال
وكان الصراع بين الاستقلال والوحدة
هل نحتاج نظام فدرالي، وللا نظام موحّد
واتفقوا ووصلوا إلى قناعة، أسميها التوافق التاريخي
اللي خلق الاستقلال الليبي، حاجتين
الحاجة الأولى: التحالف مع الحُلفاء
اللي هم كانوا ينظروا بعين التعاطف على كيان ليبي، يكون حليف لهم
بس الشيء الآخر استغلال النضال والجهاد الليبي
ضد الطليان والتضحيات
في أن رضوا بقيادة الأمير «محمد المهدي السنوسي»
اللي هو كان علاقته قوية مع الحلفاء
واللي دخل مع الحلفاء في مجموعة، متطوع
يسموها الجيش السنوسي، دخل من مصر إلى ليبيا
فبدأ الصراع على الاستقلال، وطبيعة الدولة
هل تكون فدرالية أم موحدة، وأخيرًا اتفقوا على الاستقلال
ولكن كدولة ملكيّة فدراليّة دستوريّة
ليش اختاروا أن تكون دولة ملكية؟
شيئين
القيادة اللي هو الأكثر بروزًا وتقبلًا
حفيد مؤسس الحركة السنوسيّة، وحركة قادة الجهاد الليبي
وتاريخها ناصع خاصة قادتها الأوائل
وبالتالي في رصيد كبير في الشرق والجنوب الليبي للحركة السنوسيّة
وحتى جزء من الغرب الليبي في الدواخل
وأيضًا الأمير في تلك الفترة «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
اجتهد، وكان في اجتهاده الكثير من الحصافة
كثير من الجمهوريين الليبيين، وحتى جيلنا احنا، واللي قبلنا
ينتقدوا هذه الأشياء، اللي كيف تتحالف مع الإنقليز
كيف تعطي قواعد، هذه الأشياء
وأنا أعتقد هذا نوع من القفز إلى حد كبير على هذيك المرحلة
ما كان مُتاح، وهو أن ليبيا موحّدة بتحالف مع دولة غربية
لأن الجمهورية الطرابلسية لم يكن لها حليف دولي
وحطّموها الطليان بسرعة بعد سنتين
الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
بُويع من القيادات الليبية في الجنوب الليبي
هم سنوسيين عائلة «سيف النصر»
وفي الغرب الليبي القيادات الحضريّة والبدويّة والريفيّة
توصّلت إلى أن، على مضض لا بد أن نقبل ببيعة
واستخدموا شيء من التقاليد الإسلاميّة والعربيّة، والبيعة
بيعة الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي» اللي هو أمير البلاد
هذا التوافق اللي هو أنا برأيي كان توافق مهم وتاريخي
سواءً انتقدناها أم لا
لأن هذا جدل، ولكن كبير عليه
وخاصة بعد الـ 1969 جُدّد هذا الجدل
فأدّى إلى نضال شعبي، وتأجيج من أجل استقلال ليبيا
وضد تقسيم ليبيا إلى ثلاث دول
فكانت في خطة تقسيم؟
نعم، كان في برنامج ما بين الفرنسيين والطليان
والبريطانيين إلى حد كبير
يسمّوها «بيفن سفورزا» وزراء الخارجية كانوا بقسموا ليبيا
إيطاليا تعود إلى الوصاية الإيطالية
فزان تحت الوصاية الفرنسية، وبرقة تحت الوصاية البريطانية
إلى حد كبير
فما حصل، صار في اتحاد؟
صار في اتحاد من أحد القيادات
وصار في تأجيج شعبي ضد «بيفن سفورزا» والتقسيم
الشعب الليبي، قطاعات كثيرة نظّمت نفسها، وتظاهرت
ورسلت رسائل وتلقرامات، وصعدت المسألة
طبعًا إنشاء الجامعة العربيّة في ذيك الفترة ساعده
وخاصة أن أول أمين لجامعة الدول العربيّة
وهو السّيد «عبدالرحمن عزام»
كان من ضمن، انضم للمقاومة والجهاد الليبي
وكان أحد مستشاري الجمهورية الطرابلسية
وزوجته الأولى والثانية ليبيات
شوف التّداخل مرّة أخرى، التّداخل العربي في المنطقة
في نفس السياق، وأنا لازم أقول لك على المسألة هذه
«بورقيبة» من أصل ليبي، جدّه من مصراتة
«بن بلة» أسرته من أصل مغربي، من مراكش
وأعتقد أن الآن صعب شوية، لأن الحدود صارت مرسومة
والدول صار عندها أكثر وضوحًا في حدودها
لكن حتى منتصف القرن العشرين
العالم العربي الإسلامي كان فيه نوع من السيولة
(Fluidity) زي ما نقول باللغة الإنقليزية
سيولة للتنقل والزواج والإقامة
وبذلك لا بد أن ننظر لهذا بعين الاعتبار، إذا بنحكي على توافق التاريخ
على أيّة حال، أنا برأيي هذا التوافق التاريخي، الغائب الآن
القيادات الليبية تكفّر
وتمارس خطاب الاغتيال المعنوي والشخصي
لكن الذي خلق الاستقلال الليبي
هو هذا التوافق التاريخ بين القيادات الليبية
وبذلك في بمباركة، ودعم القوة الغربية
وبالذات بريطانيا في البداية، والولايات المتحدة فيما بعد
واستقلت ليبيا كملكية دستوريّة فدرالية
لكن عام 1963 قرّروا أنه بحكم النفط والمصاريف وغيرها
صارت ليبيا موحّدة، وألغي النظام الفدرالي
أيش الفرق، هي كانت المملكة المتحدة الليبية؟
المملكة الليبية المتحدة
عام 1951؟
إي
بعدين أيش اللي حصل عام 1962 خلاها تتغير؟
شيئين في عاملين
العامل الأول: أن النفط أكتشف في ليبيا في نهاية الخمسينيات
وفجأة ليبيا انتقلت من أفقر دول العالم
إلى وحدة من أغنى دول العالم
إلى دولة غنية
وبعدين بالسبعينيات صارت من الدول النفطية القليلة في المنطقة
فاللي صار أن إدارة الاقتصاد الليبي، أعتقد
تطلبت أن تكون فيه مركزية في التخطيط
والنظام الفدرالي كان في ثلاث حكومات
عاصمتين ومجالس تشريعية
كانت بيرقراطية، رغم أن الآن الفدراليين بعد 2011
بعد سقوط القذافي
يعطوا صورة وردية، وحالمة على النظام الفدرالي
لازم أكون منصف لهم
لأني أعتقد أن التهميش اللي صار بعد القذافي
خاصة المنطقة الشرقية مُهم
ولازم الواحد يكون حسّاس، وفاهم مشاعرهم
أنا أتفهم هذا جيدًا، لكن النظام الفدرالي
النظام المالكي نفسه النخبة، وصلت إلى قناعة
أنه من الناحية العملية غير مُجدي، وتكوّن نظام ممتاز
أنا أتمنى أن الليبيين الآن يعيدوا اكتشافه
نظام المحافظات، ليبيا بدل ثلاث ولايات
صار فيها أكثر من عشر محافظات، وكان فيها نظام محلي
العبرة في نهاية الأمر، أخوي عبدالرحمن، المسألة مش في الأسامي
هل من الناحية الفعلية فيه يكون الحكم محلي وتمكين للناس
أنهم يديروا شؤونهم الاقتصادية والإدارية والقضائية والتعليمية
بشكل حقيقي، وللا لا؟
لأن بكل سهولة نقدر نعمل الدستور، والبرنامج الفلاني
ونعمل الشركة الفلانية
لكن في نهاية الأمر، كيف نطبّق هذه الأشياء؟
فالتاريخ الاجتماعي الليبي، والصراع من أجل الاستقلال
كان معقّد
جت رحمة وبركة من ربي
أن الطليان هُزموا في الحرب العالمية الثانية
وهذا فتح الفرصة للقوى المعارضة
والشعب الليبي أن يُعيد ترتيب أدواته
كانت قيادات عبقريّة، ومُلتزمة وكُفؤة
اللي هي كانت تناضل من أجل الاستقلال في المنفى
وخاصة في دمشق
جمعية «الدفاع الطرابلسي البرقاوي»
وكان من ضمنهم شخصية مميزة جدًّا
وزعيم بارز اسمه الأستاذ «بشير السعداوي»
اللي هو كان أحد مستشاري الملك «عبد العزيز» رحمة الله عليه
لما نُفي، وكان تعلم التعليم العثماني
وكان شخصية بارزة في المنطقة الغربية
وكوّن حزب «المؤتمر الطرابلسي» فيما بعد
فليبيا الحديثة تكوّنت من خلال هذه الصراعات المحلية والإقليمية
والصراع من أجل الاستقلال، وكانت مركّبة ومعقّدة
فجيل «القذافي» هذا موضوع آخر
لكن خلينا نُعرّج على موضوع دموي وبشع
في المعتقلات اللي احنا
بس أنا بعرّج على، أحس في كم نقطة ودّي أرجع لها
بس بمشي بترتيب معين
تفضل
برجع إلى القرن السادس عشر
ليبيا تحت الحكم العُثماني، كيف علاقتها بالدولة العُثمانيّة؟
سؤال وجيه
كانت ولاية طرفية، تسمى ولاية طرابلس الغرب
ما كانت تُسمى ليبيا؟
لا، كما ذكرت لك من نحو ساعة، يا أخ عبدالرحمن
كان اسم ليبيا، زي تونس، كانت «يالاتونس»
والجزائر كانت دولة الدايات في الجزائر
اسم ليبيا
هو اسم قديم، في قبائل ليبو من الفترة الرومانية القديمة جدًّا
ولكن الرومان كانوا يسمّون ليبيا، نسبة للقبائل الليبية، ليبيا
فالطليان وحدة
أحد الأشياء اللي حاولوا أنهم يبرّروا فيها غزوهم لليبيا
يقولوا: احنا مش جايين لليبيا كاستعمار
احنا نعود في البحر المتوسط كانت بُحيرة رومانية
وليبيا كانت جزء من الإمبراطورية الرومانية، ونحن ورثتها
شوف العجب والكذب
هكذا تبريرهم للاستعمار؟
جزء من الخطاب الرسمي
يقولوا: احنا عدنا إلى ليبيا، هذه جزء منا، لنا
كما أن البحر المتوسط كان بحيرة رومانية
ونحن الفاشيون الجُدد، أقصد المستعمرون الطليان في 2011
وخاصة الفاشيين، يقولون: نحن ورثة الإمبراطورية الرومانية
فلو سألت أي عربي، مثلًا في القرن السابع عشر عن ليبيا
ما بعرف شيء اسمه ليبيا؟
يقول لك: طرابلس، حتى الآن
بس لو قلت له: ليبيا، ممكن ما يعرف أيش تقصد؟
الآن الليبيين، العرب يفهموا ليبيا، لأن الاسم كان من 1951 للآن
إي الآن معلوم، بس أنا أتكلم قديم
هل هذا هو اللي كان حاضر، كان غائب تمامًا هذا الاسم؟
يقولوا: طرابلس
والأخوة في تونس، اللي هم قريبين من الشعب الليبي كثير
لأن العائلات عندكم، كما تقول: الجزيرة العربيّة
تلقى جزء من شمال اليمن وجنوبه تلقاهم هنا وهناك
ما بين الكويت والسعودية
شمّر تلقاها في العراق والسعودية، وسوريا مثلًا
نفس العملية في ليبيا وتونس، خاصة الجنوب التونسي
بدليل أن «بورقيبة»
زي ما حكيت لك، جدّه الأكبر كان من مدينة مصراتة
ولهذا كان الليبي، يقول لك: طرابلس
فكانت هي ولاية غرب
طرابلس الغرب
تمييزها عن طرابلس الشام، كان في طرابلسين
واسم طرابلس، حتى مشاهديك يفهموا هذا
هو اسم روماني قديم، كان فيه ثلاث مُدن بيزنطية ورومانية
اللي هي «صبراتة» و«لبتاماغنس» و«أويا»
وطرابلس هي المدن الثلاثة، اللي هي «تيبولس»
تغيّرت باللغة العربيّة، وصارت طارابلس أو طرابلس
عجيب والله
فكان في طرابلس الشرق
طرابلس الشام وطرابلس الغرب
ولايا طرابلس الغرب، اللي هي من منتصف القرن السادس عشر
كانت فترة فيه استقلالية، دولة «قُرمانلية» حكمت
هي ضابط عُثماني استقل، كما صار فيه ولايات عُثمانية أخرى
تسمى الدولة القرمانلية
ولكن خوف الدولة العُثمانيّة من مجيء
واستغلت حرب أهلية ما بين أعضاء في الأسرة القرمانلية
فبعثت بالجيش والأسطول العثماني
خوفًا من سقوط طرابلس، كما سقطت الجزائر وتونس
فطرابلس الغرب، أخ عبدالرحمن، هي آخر ولاية عُثمانيّة
في شمال إفريقيا، ولهذا
لكن في الشرق الليبي، أحيانًا المتصرفية في بنغازي
كانت متصرفية مستقلة تتبع الدولة العُثمانيّة
ولكن بشكل عام لما أقول، حتى في تركيا تقول..
أمازح الأخوة الأتراك، أقول لهم: أنا من طرابلس الغرب
يبتسموا، لأن عارف أن الذاكرة التاريخية، ورموزها لها معنى كبير
ليبيا، حتى أعطيك إجابة أكثر، آخر نقطة في الإجابة على هذا السؤال
ليبيا من ناحية التأثير العُثماني طويل
ولكن التأثير العثماني كان دائمًا يتركّز على المُدن
الدواخل، المدن طرابلس والخُمس ومصراتة والزاوية
بنغازي ودرنة، الدواخل كانت مستقلة
مستقلة بحيث أنها تحكم نفسها بنفسها؟
من الناحية الاسمية تتبع الدولة العُثمانيّة
ولكن من الناحية الفعلية كانت
زي ما شفنها الحركة السنوسيّة، كانت تحت حُكم ذاتي مُستقل
يُنافس الدولة العُثمانيّة في الدواخل
الدواخل اللي هي المناطق الداخلية
هذا اسم نستخدمه احنا كثير في شمال إفريقيا
وفي القرن السادس عشر، وحتى بداية القرن التاسع عشر
في فزان تكونت دولة أسّسها أحد الأشراف من مدينة فاس
اسمه «محمد بن إدريس الفاسي»
احنا نسميها دولة «أولاد محمد»
«محمد» هو لفظ عندنا في شمال إفريقيا
بدل ما نقول، أحيانًا نقول: محمد وأحمد
لكن أيضًا عندنا باللهجة المغربية، نقول: محمّد
في الصعيد اكتشفت أن حتى الإخوان الصعايدة المصريين
يقولوا: محمّد أيضًا، فيسموا مُحمّد وأحمد
وأيضًا محمّد، لما يدلعوا الليبيين مُحمد، يا عبدالرحمن
وهذه ممكن تهمك، يقولوا: محمد يسمّوه حميدة
ولهذا أنا جدّي، كان عمي، أجدادي الاثنين
عندهم واحد «محمد الكبير» و«محمد الصغير»
فالصغير اسمه «حميدة الصغيّر»
وصار اسمك علي أحميدة؟
علي عبداللطيف أحميدة، الصغيّر
فهذه اللغة والتقاليد مهمّة في هذه
ممتاز، إذا برجع للدولة العُثمانيّة
الآن في 1986 بدأ الاستعمار الإيطالي لليبيا؟
1911 الغزو
الغزو، بس أنت فصّلتها إلى أنها
قسمت أنت الاستعمار الإيطالي إلى قسمين
نعم
أنه استعمار اقتصادي أيديولوجي بدأ من 1886 إلى 1911؟
وفي الغزو العسكري من 1911 إلى
لا، هو اللي صار، يا عبدالرحمن، أن الطليان لما بدأوا في التفكير
كانوا عيونهم يُبغوا يأخذوا تونس، يستعمروها
الفرنسيين أخذوها منهم في 1881 حسنًا؟
وفي جالية إيطالية كبيرة في تونس حتى الستينيات
ولكن لما الفرنسيين استعمروا تونس
لحماية مستعمرتهم الكبيرة والمهمة، الجزائر
ووجدوا تواطئ من الأسرة الحسينيّة اللي هم بايات تونس
الطليان بدأوا في التفاوض مع الفرنسيين والألمان والإنقليز
ووافقوا، أُعطت لهم ولاية طرابلس الغرب
في مقابل اعترافهم بحقوق الفرنسية في المغرب وتونس
بينما إيطاليا كانت تبغى تونس؟
في الأول تبي تونس
ورغبتهم في تونس، وليبيا بأي دافع؟
المشروع الاستعماري هو مشروع كان توسّعي
لأن الدول الأوربية كانت تعتقد أنه عندها حق للتوسع
من الناحية الاقتصادية والديمغرافية
واعتقدت أنها بررتها بأنها تبي مصادر للثروة
ومصادر للاستيطان وأسواق
وبررتها أنها من حقها كدول متقدمة ومتمدّنة
أنها تستعمر الدول الضعيفة
اللي يسموها «عبء الرجل الأبيض»
أو الأيديولوجية الرومانية، نحن أحفاد الإمبراطورية الرومانية
ففي أعذار وأيديولوجيات سخيفة ومضحكة
ولكن هذه إشكالية الاستعمار، كان احنا ما نعرفه كعرب
أن الاستعمار والأيديولوجية الاستعمارية
اتجاه الشعوب الغير مُستعمرّة كانت عنصرية ومتعمقة
في العلم والتعليم والثقافة والمجتمعات الأوربية
وصارت، حتى مثلًا أنا أذكر أن في كتاب قرأه طلبتي
أن حتى العلماء بدأوا يفكروا
يقولوا: والله أن في الطبيعة، في أشجار وحيوانات تنقرض
وبذلك في شعوب من حقها أنها تستمر
لأن عندها قدرة على القوة والمناعة وكل شيء
والشعوب التعبانة هذه والمتخلفة وكذا، تنقرض شيء طبيعي
فصار نوع من تطبيع العنصرية والاستعمار، وحتى الإبادة
الحين احنا نتفق أن من 1886 إلى 1911 كان في
ليش يا عبدالرحمن مركّز على 1886؟
ليش أنت تبغى تشيل الـ 1886؟
أنا بجي على 1911، بس هنا كان في حضور اقتصادي
دخول لإيطاليا على ليبيا من هذا الجانب، وللا؟
هي بدأت، عبدالرحمن، في الإعداد لما خسروا تونس
أنت في كتابك تقول بالحرف
«أن الاستعمار الإيطالي بين عامي 1886 إلى 1911
كان بدافع اقتصادي أيديولجي»
في شرق إفريقيا في إريتريا، أول مستعمرّة كانت
أول مستعمرّة لهم اشتروها في إريتريا
وبعدين المستعمرّة الثانية كانت ليبيا
قبل ليبيا، نعم، قبل طرابلس
قبل 1911؟
نعم
وكان في اللي هو عن طريق الإقراض و«مصرف روما»
داروا، جاء عملوا «بنك روما»
جاء بإعطاء قروض بشروط كثير ممتازة للناس
والفكرة، هدف البنك ما كان نجاح اقتصادي
هو شراء الأراضي، والتغلغل في المجتمع
خلق فئات مرتبطة اقتصاديًّا ونفسيًّا واجتماعيًّا بالمشروع الاستعماري
وبدأوا يكوّنوا مدارس وصُحف
أو يبعثوا في رحّالة للتمهيد لها، للغزو
فهم بدأوا بالتمهيد الاقتصادي اللي حضرتك ذكرته، صحيح
لكن الطليان مروا بمشكلة أن هُزموا من الحبشة
في 1896 في معركة عدوة
كان عندهم جنرال طائش ومغامر ومغرور
فأكل على رأسه من الأحباش، وانهزموا
ولحد الآن المشروع الاستعماري في بداية القرن العشرين
يبكوا على معركة عدوة، ولا بد من الانتقام منها
فشوف كيف الذاكرة التاريخيّة الاستعماريّة الأوربية
واحنا العرب لازم نهتم مش بس للي صار في بلداننا
لا بد أن ندرس التاريخ الأوربي والثقافة الأوربيّة
والمخاوف والتحيزات والرموز، وكيف يفسروا في الأشياء هذه
بذلك هذا كان له تبعات فيما بعد على غزو الجزائر وتونس وليبيا
وبقية البلدان العربيّة اللي استعمرت بشكل مباشر
لما تقول: أن بدافع اقتصادي واضح أيديولجي
أيش كانت الأيديولوجية اللي كانوا يبغوا؟
الأيديولوجية الاستعمارية تبرير، التغلغل الاقتصادي والديموغرافي
في الجزائر وليبيا في خلاف عن بقية المناطق الأخرى
أيش الاختلاف؟
وهي أن كانوا ينظروا على الجزائر وليبيا
على أساس أنها هي جُزء من إيطاليا وفرنسا
وكان في خطة محددة لإرسال مستوطنين
الفرنسيين كان عندهم نحو مليون مستوطن
الأقدام السوداء في الجزائر
وفي ليبيا كانوا بدل ما يعطوا أراضي للفلّاحين الطليان
خاصة في الجنوب الإيطالي في صقلية، سيسيليا
جاؤوا بحل آخر، خطّطوا لتوطين نصف مليون فلّاح إيطالي في ليبيا
وكيف تبريرهم، يا عبدالرحمن
قالوا الآتي، أنا قرأت الأدبيات الاستعمارية والصحف
والإعلانات وكتب عن هذا الموضوع
قالوا: والله أن مهاجرينا في أمريكا وأمريكا اللاتينية
تصرّف معهم، ويُهانوا
احنا نبغى مستعمرّة جزء منّا، وبذلك أن نوطن فيها مواطنينا
ويكونوا رايقين ومستانسين، وما عندهم أي مشكلة
المشكلة زي ما صار في فلسطين الآن
أن في ناس، في فلسطينيين وجزائريين مسلمين وعرب
وفي أمازيغ وليبيين مسلمين وعرب
فبدأ هذا طبيعة الصراع الأيديولجي
وأنا أقول لك: التبريرات الأكاديمية اللي احنا ما نقرأها العرب
نقرأ اللي كُتب وترجم عنا
لكن كنا نقرأ بالإيطالي والفرنسي وبالإنقليزي
وخاصة اللغة الإنقليزية الآن المهيمنة، المصادر موجودة
لما تقرأ في المصادر الأولوية، وأنا دائمًا كنت أعمل في شيء
من بداية تكويني الأكاديمي، أني كنت لا أدرس هذه القضايا
من جانب المصادر الثانوية
كنت أدرس الأرشيف كمؤرّخ، أعمل المقابلات الشفهية
وأمارس العمل الميداني، أروح بآلة التصوير وبشاشة تسجيل
وهذا اللي عملته، وأفادني لأني أعتقد الأرشيف لازم
مُهم الأرشيف، أنا لا أقول أنهم غير مهم
لكن الأرشيف هو كُتب بلغة المهيمن المستعمر
وخياراته، ماذا تذكر، وماذا تنسى
ما هو المسكوت عنه، وما هو المتاح، وما هو مخفي
ولهذا أنا أزعم، ليس في الحالة الليبية فحسب
أن كثير من التاريخ العربي، وخاصة تاريخ المجتمع
مسكوت عنه ومخفي، ولم يُكتب بعد
وهذه فرصة للأجيال الجاية اللي تكون إعداد منهجي
وإعداد لغوي، وتفكير ناقد
أن يعيدوا إثارة أسئلة جديدة على مواضيع نعتقد أنها محسومة، وهي لا
1911 جاء الاستعمار العسكري الإيطالي
في كتابك قلت: أدّى الاستعمار الإيطالي إلى زلزلة عنيفة
نعم
للمجتمع الليبي، ودّي أعرف ما طبيعة هذه الزلزلة؟
العنف، جيش حديث ومدرّعات وبنادق حديثة
مدافع، وبوارج تضرب بعنف
نعطيك مثال معركة شارع الشط في البداية
خارج ضواحي طرابلس
فُوجئ الطليان، وهذا كان من صالح اللييبيين
اعتقدوا أن الدعاية الإيطالية
كانت بتقول: أن الليبيين كانوا متخلّفين ومضطهدين وبؤساء
لأن الحكم العثماني كان سيء
واحنا جينا لننقذهم ونطوّرهم ونمدّنهم
فلما بدأ الغزو في بداية أكتوبر
كيف تقبّل الليبيّون هذا الكلام، والدعاية؟
هذه الدعاية، الغالبية العظمى ضحكوا على المسألة في البداية
لكن خلّيني أكون أكثر إنصافًا، وهذا الكلام الليبيين دائمًا يهربوا منه
في فئات تواطأت، يا عبدالرحمن
مثلًا عميد مدينة طرابلس كان يحلم أنه يصير البايرن لتونس
أن الفرنسيين يعمّدوه كحاكم، ويحكم من خلالهم
أو من خلال التوافق معه، فهو ساعد في عملية الغزو
في أسر ليبيّة كانت عندها صراعات مع الدولة العُثمانيّة وخلافات
واعتقدوا أنهم قوّوا خصومهم في مصراتة وطرابلس والجبل
ضدهم، وبذلك لم يعتقدوا أنه تواضع
يعتقدوا أنه احنا نبغى نأخذ حقنا
وبذلك في مثلًا أسر وزعامات
قالت: والله احنا جبنا للطليان نعم، من أجل هذا
أيش إشكال المساعدات والتواطؤ؟
فتح الحصون والمساعدة والدخول في الجيش
نعم، معلومات استخباراتية على الحصون، وعسكرية
أحيانًا جمع السّلاح، ومستشارين للغزو الإيطالي
لكن الشيء اللي هو لم يتوقعّه الجيش الإيطالي
في نهاية 1911 أن تكون في مقاومة منظّمة بأسلحة بدائية
ولكن مجتمع منظّم لم يكن مؤدلج
كان متماسك، وكأنه يُناضل من أجل الإسلام والوطن
هذه كانت الفكرة الأساسية فيه
وأعتقد أن مثلًا في شارع الشط عشان، صارت مذبحة
أيش اللي حصل؟
الجيش الإيطالي تقدم بعدما ضرب دكّ المُدن
الخُمس وطرابلس وزاوية وبنغازي ودرنة وكذا
واحتل في البداية، تقدّم
لأن القوة التكنولوجيّة والعسكرية
كانت شيء لا يتصور خاصة بالنسبة لليبيين
فتقدّموا والمجاهدين عملوا لهم كمين، منطقة شارع الشط
وقتلوا مجموعة من الضباط والجنود
انتقم الجيش الإيطالي بارتكاب مجزرة أدّت إلى وفاة
ما بين 3-4 آلاف من بينهم أطفال ونساء وغيره
معروفة أنها مذبحة شارع الشط، فكانت شَرِسة
خليني أعطيك قصة شوية لطيفة، عشان نخفّف على المشاهدين
كانت في أسلحة
لا تنسى أن الناس في ليبيا في هذيك الفترة أو طرابلس
وبرقة في هذيك الفترة وفزان
كانوا الحكم، الناس كانت تحمل السلاح
عشان قُطعانهم وأملاكهم وأرزاقهم ومزارعهم
لأن الدولة المركزية العُثمانيّة كانت محدودة
حتى مسألة الخطف والسرقة وكذا، مُهم بالنسبة لهم
فالسلاح والتّدرب على السلاح كان مهم
والطريقة السنوسيّة لعبت دور حافل في الإعداد على الأمد البعيد
عبقريّة الحركة السنوسيّة أنها
لأن مؤسسها كان عالم جزائري، ولم يستطيع العودة إلى بلده
ولهذا كان فكرة لا لن نبدأ بالسلاح، بإعداد الإنسان
التعليم والتجارة والتركيز على الاكتفاء الذاتي
والشيء اللي أنا أفكر فيه أحيانًا، نقول: هذا الرجل خارق الذكاء
وعنده بُعد نظر غير عادي
هو وأتباعه والقادة اللي فيما بعدها
بدأوا في منتصف القرن التاسع عشر
خلال خمسين سنة، وهم يبنوا في مجتمع
لما جاء الطليان، واجهوا مجتمع متماسك رغم أنه فقير، ويمكن حافي
وأكله، تمر ولبن وشوية حاجات بسيطة
ولكن مُتماسك وعنده معرفة، ووعي باستقلاليته
والخطر الذي جاء في البلدان المجاورة الجزائر وتونس
وبذلك ما كانوا خارج المنطقة ككل
وما يجري فيها من الناحية هذه
وكتاباتهم ومراسلاتهم تُشير إلى أن كان في وعي عميق بأعدائهم
هل كانوا يعتقدون أن الفرنسيين اللي راح يهاجمونهم
وللا كانوا على دراية بالإيطاليين؟
الحركة السنوسية لما جاء الفرنسيين في تشاد
وبدأوا في التوغل فدافعوا عن زواياهم
الزوايا اللي زي ما
عشان المشاهدين والمستمعين عندنا في الجزيرة العربيّة والمشرق
الزاوية هو لفظ مغربي، يعني مسجد احنا نقول له: زاوية
اللي هو بالنسبة للسنوسّة كان مسجد أو مدرسة أو فندق
أو مجلس قضائي، ويتبرّع الأهالي والناس
بالأرض وبالعمل ووقف من أجل هذه الزاوية
والحركة السنوسيّة كانت توفّر العلماء والأئمة والمدرسين والمدربين
لما بدأ المدربين على السلاح والحِرَف
مكتبة «المعهد الأعلى» في الجغبوب كانت فيها آلاف الكتب
والطليان دمّروها فيما بعد
فهنا يأتي شيء، مُعظم المؤرخين الليبيين يقفزوا عليه
وهو دائمًا يركزون على الجهاد
أنا برأيي النجاح الأكبر الحركة السنوسيّة والجمهوريّة الطرابلسية
والصفوف
خاصة الصف الفوقي في صفوف التحالفات الفلاحية القبلية
ميزتها أنها كوّنت من خلال تراثها ومؤسساتها
أدوات لتنظيم نفسها ليس فقط في القرن التاسع عشر
ولكن حتى في مواجهة هذا الغول الكبير الذي جاء بأساطيله
ومدافعه ودبّاباته وطائراته لأول مرّة البدائية
ولهذا، هذا التماسك يفسّر الاستمرارية
وأنا أزعم نجاح الطريقه السنوسيّة ليس في الجهاد والقتال
في تأسيس وتنوير المجتمع المحلي
وتوحيده، يا عبدالرحمن، مش بالخطب وبالمواعظ
لا، توحيده من خلال رؤية جديدة لكيفية بناء المؤسسات
كيف أن التعليم هو يوحّد ومفتوح على كل الفئات، ومبني على الكفاءة
وبذلك قالت الحركة السنوسيّة شيء عجيب، اللي اكتشفته
منهم من أصل يمني، وغرب وجنوب ليبيا، وتشاد
ومن الحجاز وتونس والجزائر والمغرب
قادة الإخوان، الأدوار اللي هي الجامعات العسكرية المقاتلة
اللي تضرب وتفر، كَر وفَر
وكانوا منهم خليط عجيب جدًّا
ويوحّدهم اللي هو الإسلام السنوسي السنّي الإصلاحي الجديد
فالطليان اعتقدوا
هل كان للدولة العُثمانيّة دور في المدد، وللا الجيش؟
هذا سؤال مهم
في البداية شعروا السلطان العثماني ووزرائه ونخبته، بالخجل
وشعروا بالذنب لأن الحمل، الحاميات العُثمانيّة في ليبيا
كان نحو 5 آلاف
وهناك بعض الاتهامات أن بعض الوزراء تواطئوا مع إيطاليا
في أن يخفّفوا، بحجّة مساعدة الانتفاضة في اليمن
واللي صار أن أعطوا الاستقلال للشعب الليبي لطرابلس
للناس المسلمين في طرابلس
ولكن كانت كأنها حسنًا أنتم الآن مستقلين، جاؤوكم الطليان
ربنا يوفقكم، ولكن أعطيناكم الاستقلال
فكانت هي أضعف الإيمان، ولكن مش أضعفه
كانت نوع من حفظ ماء الوجه
والسلاح اللي يجي من مصر
هل كان من مصر، وللا من خلال الدولة العُثمانيّة؟
الدولة العُثمانيّة لعبت دور كبير
فيما بعد عن طريق الجمعية «تشكيلاتي مخصوص» وهذه جمعية سرية
وأخذ بعض أبناء الوجهاء والأعيان وتدريبهم
«خاصة أنور باشا» لعب دور مُهم في البداية
«مصطفى كمال» كان في الجبهة الشرقية في درنة
وفي النضال ضد الطليان، وفيما وبعد
بعد دخول الأمبراطورية العُثمانيّة بعد التردد في جانب ألمانيا
في الحرب العالمية الأولى بعثوا بمساعدات أكبر
ولكن للتاريخ وللإنصاف، يا عبدالرحمن
هناك جنود وضباط أتراك عُثمانيين، وفي ناس من العالم العربي
زي ضباط عراقيين ومصريين وسوريين ويمنيين
بعض منهم قرّروا الانضمام للمقاومة الليبية والمجاهدين
وفي منهم اللي ماتوا، واستشهدوا في ليبيا، في هذه الفترة
فهي فترة دموية ومرعبة، ولكن فيها جوانب كثير مشرقة وإنسانية
ومجهولة للأسف الشديد
لأن أنا سؤالي الأصلي في الكتاب الأول
لماذا واجه المجتمع في ليبيا، ذيك الفترة ليبيا العُثمانيّة بقوة متعددة؟
وليش ردود الفعل الاستعمار الإيطالي كان متنوع أو متعدد؟
وما هي التبعات والعواقب المباشرة وغير المباشرة
للاستعمار الإيطالي بين 1911 إلى 1943 لما هُزم الحلفاء
بما فيهم الحُلفاء النازيين الألمان والفاشيين الإيطاليين في هذيك الفترة
فقصدي هذه الفترة شحذت...
فجأة وجد الناس والرأي العام
أن دولة شرسة وقوية جاءت
تقول: هذا البلد لي، وأنا جئت لأحضّركم بالحديد والنار
جمعية «الدفاع الطرابلسي البرقاوي»
عندهم كتاب حلو جدًّا وجميل وعبقري
«التمدين بالحديد والنار، الفضائع الحُمر السود»
وهو كتاب صغير، ولكن يوثّق فضائع الفاشية الإيطالية
من جانب عربي إسلامي
وهذا اكتشتف فيما بعد صار مُهم لما بدأت في الكتاب الثالث
اللي هو بعد «الدولة والاستعمار»
«الأصوات المهمّشة» اللي هو الكتاب الثالث
«الإبادة الجماعية في ليبيا: الشر، تاريخ استعماري مخفي»
بالنسبة للأقاليم الثلاثة
هل اختلفت المقاومة بين الأقاليم الثلاثة الموجودة في ليبيا؟
نعم، المنطقة الغربية اللي أكثر كثافة واستقرارًا
قاومت حتى 1915، وفيها، خلينا نتوقف شوية
لأن صارت فيها معركة مهمّة جدًّا
اللي هي؟
معركة القرضابية، اتّحدت القوى
القوات تحت راية الحركة السنوسيّة من الشرق
سيد «صفي الدين السنوسي»
ومن الغرب المجاهد «رمضان السويحلي»
والقادة من الغرب الليبي
ومن الجنوب القائد البارز الكاريزماتي «أحمد سيف النصر»
وانقضت، كان قوات الغرب الليبي يفرض أنها تكون «باندا»
«باندا» يعني تشتغل تابعة للقوات الإيطالية، ولكن انقلبت عليها
واتحدت القوات من الأقاليم الثلاثة، وهزمت الجيش الإيطالي
وأنهت الحياة المهنية العسكرية للجنرال «مياني»
وأُسر، وقُتل العديد من الضباط والجنود الطليان
واستطاع المُجاهدين أن يستولوا على آلاف المدافع والبنادق
وأكياس التموين والأرزاق وغيرها
وكانت معركة ممتازة، منها أدّى إلى الطليان بدأوا يتفاوضوا
خاصة في هذيك الفترة، أعطى استقلال محدود
الحكم الذاتي للإمارة السنوسيّة
واعترفوا بالجمهورية الطرابلسية في البداية 1918
وأعطوا استقلالية للجنوب الليبي
تحت السّيد «أحمد سيف النصر» و«عبدالجليل سيف النصر»
فهذه المعركة مهمّة
الوجود الإيطالي كان في المُدن الساحليّة
في بنغازي ودرنة وسوسة والخُمس وطرابلس والزاوية بس
وهذا نتيجة للهزيمة الكبيرة في معركه القرضابية
فيما بعد جاء الفاشيين، وقرّروا أن لا حُكم ذاتي
لا تهاون مع القيادات الليبية العربيّة والمسلمة
وبدأوا في عملية إعادة الغزو، بالإيطالي
واستمرت عملية الغزو من
في المنطقة الغربية نجحوا في هزيمة المقاومة
نقول: 1923
اضطر جُل السكان والقيادات والقبائل والزعامات للهجرة
إما لتونس، يا إما لجنوب ليبيا في فزان
يا إما لتشاد، يا إما لمصر
وأنا أسرتي، جد جدي، اثنين، واحد منهم اختفى
اعتقدوا أهلنا أنه مات
واكتشفوا أنه في قبيلة ليبية اسمها المغاربة ورفلة، أخفوه
لأنه كان معلم قرآن وشريف
ورجع لهم بعد عشر سنوات، واكتشفوا أنه ما زال حي
جدي الآخر والد والدتي، اضطر للهجرة
لأن الطليان كانوا يبغوا يشنقوه، حكموا عليه بالإعدام
وعاش في المنفى، في شمال تشاد في مدينة اسمها فايا لارجو
اسم فرنسي لارجو، بس فايا هذا الاسم معروف للعرب فيها
فالمهم من هذه التفاصيل الآتي
الطليان نجحوا في النهاية بعد عشرين سنة
من حرب دموية وعنيفة وشرسة
في قتل ونفي وتهجير كُل الفئات المقاومة أو المجاهدة لمشروعهم
بالنسبة للمعتقلات اللي أنت قلتها، كانت في نفس هذه الفترة، وللا؟
نعم، لكن اللي صار أن المعتقلات هي جزء من السياسة العنيفة
نحن لن نرضى إلا باستسلام كامل
وقبل لا نتكلم عن مسألة المعتقلات، خليني أضيف معلومة مهمة
أنا قلت: الشعب الليبي واجه غزوة شرسة
ولكن برغم القتل والمنافي والآلة الحديثة، الجيش الإيطالي
الاستعمار الإيطالي لليبيا، بحسب تقديري المتواضع
شحذ النفوس، وعرّف الليبيين مَن هُم
ولهذا الآن يحكوا لي على أزمة الهوية
وأقول لهم: كلام فازغ، هرطقة هذه
الليبيين زي ما قالت والدتي: معروفين، لكن في أزمة سياسية
في فشل نخبه وفساد صحيح، لكن ما تحكي على المواطن العادي
تقول له: من أنت؟
زي ما قالت والدتي، علي أنت أيش فيك؟
زي ما تقولوا أنتوا باللهجة السعودية
أنا ليبية ومسلمة وعربية، ما في مشكلة أي شيء
نعود الآن إلى المعتقلات
الطليان ضربوا بيد حديد، ولكن للأسف الشديد
لا بد أن الليبيين يعترفون أن فئات استطاعوا أن يتغلغلوا
ويجندوا فئات متواطئة، بدليل أن الجيش الإيطالي
في نهاية العشرينيات، ثلثه كان من الليبيين وإريتريين
يسمّوه العسكري، يقول لك: الحبش
والليبيين يقولوا: مصوّع، لأنه من ميناء مصوع
لكن هم الطليان، يقولوا لهم: عسكري في الأدبيات الإيطالية
يسموهم العسكري
وهو اسم عربي، لكن صار جزء من اللغات الأوربيّة
يقول لك: عسكري، في شرق إفريقيا وشمال
وخاصة في ليبيا، يقول لك: (The Ascaris)
حتى باللغة الإنقليزية والإيطالية تُكتب (Ascaris)
اللي صار أن، برأيي هذا جدّر الهوية
احنا قاومنا من أجل ديننا ووطننا وهويتنا
لأن الاستعمار الإيطالي لم يعطنا أي فُرص أخرى
وحلقة مهمة بجانب المذابح والآلة العسكرية الكبيرة
«قراتسياني» واحد من الجنرالات الدمويين، يسموه سفّاح ليبيا
«رودولفو قراتسياني» هذا أيش عمل، يا عبدالرحمن
لأن الإمدادات كانت تأتي من مصر
متطوعين، ناس عرب ومسلمين، وليبيين في المنفى
يبعثوا في الأرزاق والسلاح، ولكن الناس كانت في حالة حرب
ما تقدر تحرث وتزرع وتعمل
جت فترة من الفترات، لاحظت أن لما يأتي وقت الحصاد في الأول
كانوا يبطلوا الجهاد، ويروحوا يحرثوا ويزرعوا، وهذا شيء طبيعي
أن في الفترة هذه عشان حياتهم اليومية، لازم يأخذوا قمح وشعير
لكن جت الفترة الأخيرة ما قدروا
فكانت تجيهم مساعدات وتموين من مصر
اللي صار أن «قراتسياني» قرّر يعمل حاجز شائك
300 كيلومتر بين ليبيا ومصر، وبعدين، يا سيدي العزيز
قام هو وثلاثة جنرالات معه
بعملية لم تسبقها أي شيء حتى في الجزائر
اللي هي فكرة المعتقلات
جاؤوا بفكرة جنونية، هي حقيقة جنونية، لكن لها معانيها
قالوا: أن «عمر المختار» والمجاهدين اللي هم 5-4 آلاف
ولكن عندهم زي ما تقول، سمك في بحيرة
زي ما تقول نظريات مكافحة التمرد، مضادة للثورات والانتفاضات
فقرروا أنهم يهجّروا كُل السّكان المدنيين من شرق ليبيا
اللي هم مرتبطين بارتباط عضوي ومؤسساتي وأيديولوجي وتعليمي
مع المقاومة والجهاد تحت قيادة كاريزمية
اللي هي شيخ الشهداء «عمر المختار»
كان صلب ومحترم وقوي العزيمة ومتواضع وبسيط
وكان معه مجموعة القادة اللي معه، رجال المقاومة والمجاهدين
فقرروا أنهم جاؤوا بخطة جنونيّة وشرّيرة
يهجّروا كل السكان المدنيين حتى يخنُقوا المقاومة
من ناحية المتطوعين والأخبار والاستخبارات والدعم والاختفاء
ووجدت أنها تقريبًا رقم ما بين 100 إلى 110 ألف بني آدم
هجّروهم من المنطقة الغنية والجميلة والزراعية في الجبل الأخضر
إلى صحراء سرت، إما عن طريق بواخر، وللا المشي
ومعهم نص مليون حيوان من قُطعانهم، إبل وغنم وماعز وخيل
وحطّوهم في ستة عشر معتقل
أسوأهم خمسة معتقلات اللي هي معتقل «الترّية» و«السلوك»
و«المقرون» و«البريقة»
وأسوأهم اللي أسميه معتقل «العقيلة»
وخاصة أقارب المجاهدين و«عمر المختار» والناس اللي كانوا منه
1929 هجّروهم، ماتوا ناس في الطريق خاصة الأطفال وكبار السن
وبعد 1929 استمر الاعتقال، واستطاعوا بالحاجز الشائك
وبالتهجير والخطة الدموية الشريرة هذه
أنهم يخنقوا المقاومة، وبدأ المقاومون يسقطوا واحد بعد الآخر
حتى قُبض على شيخ الشهداء، وحُوكم واستشهد
لكن المهم القصة اللي اختفت، يا عبدالرحمن
وهذا مهم جدًّا، أنا سعيد أنك سألتني السؤال هذا
كثير من الليبيين لا يعرفوا على المعتقلات
العرب ما يفهموا إلا «عمر المختار» وفلمه
والطليان والحلفاء غطّوا، وتستّروا على أرشيف المعتقلات
هذا الكلام لم أكتشفه من البداية
ولكن أنا بدأت رحلة بحثية سنة 2000
فرحت، وقلت أنا: الموضوع هذا كالآتي
قلت: المعتقلات هذا موضوع خطير، مين كتب عنه؟
مين الليبيين، مؤرّخ واحد بس كتب رسالة ماجستير
مشكور، وعمل اللي عليه، وخلّى لنا حاجة
كيف سمعت أنت عن موضوع المعتقلات؟
شيئين، أول حاجة من خلال دراستي أطروحة الدكتوراة
عرفت أن في معتقلات
والدتي لما كنت صغير أنا وخواتي، نقول لها
هي ثقافتها شوية عاشت في المنفى، وولدت فيه
وثقافتها لما نرد، والدتي كان فيها بقية ثقافة الدواخل
يا تقول لك بيت شعر
أنتم في الجزيرة، تقولوا، مش الشعر الفصيح
النبطي أو الشعبي
النبطي، احنا نقول: الشعر الشعبي، هو نفس الشيء
لكن هو متغلغل في ثقافة الحياة اليومية
طريقة تعبير بين الناس
كانت والدتي لما نكلماه على شيء
تقول لنا إما بيت شعر، أو مثل شعبي، وهذه ثقافتها
واحنا بعدين نخمن أيش تقول، وقصدها
فمرات نقول لها يا أمي احنا مرضى، أنا مريض
تقول لهم: مابي مرض غير دار العقيلة
وحبس القبيلة، وبُعد الجبا من بلاد الوصيلة
فيما بعد، بسادسة ابتدائي
قرأنا قصيدة لشاعر وطني كبير، اسمه «أحمد رفيق المهدوي»
اسمه «غيث الصغير»
جاء للمعتقل وكتب على «غيث الصغير»
فاحنا المدرّس خلّانا نقرأها، وبعدين عملناها مسرحية
في صف السادس الابتدائي
لما أبحث في أطروحة الدكتوراة، قلت شنو القضية هذه؟
في حاجة، هذا الموضوع يمكن مجرد قصة طرفة، أو شيء طريف
وللا في شيء بشع وأوسع وعميق؟
اكتشفت يا عبدالرحمن
أن الموضوع، نجح الطليان في أن يردموا، ويخفوا هذه الجريمة
اكتشفت أنها كانت 110 ألف بني آدم
اللي هجّروا من الشرق؟
إيوة، وبعدين قلت أنا: لازم، هذا الموضوع خطير
كان عندي أستاذ هو زي ما تقول، شيخي باللغة الأكاديمية
وليس اللغة القديمة
هو أستاذ عربي أمريكي، العرب لا تعرف عنه الكثير
لكن كان عبقري وصلب اسمه «رفعت علي أبو الحاج سلطان»
فلسطيني أمريكي
فمرّة أحكي أنا وإيّاه في 1999 أذكر هذا تحديدًا
قلت له: يا رفعت
أنا الآن أبغى أبدأ في البحث، والتحقيق في هذا الموضوع
لأني ما لقيت شيء عليه يملئ العين، لا بالعربي، ولا بالإنقليزي
لقيت كتاب واحد، وكله طراطيش، وأنا نبي نحقق، أيش صار؟
اكتشفت أني ما نعرف عنه شيء
رغم أني أنا من المتخصصين في المرحلة الاستعمارية
ضحك، قال لي: علي راح يأخذ منك هذا على الأقل عقد من الزمان
قال لي: يأخذ منك عشر سنين
قلت له: يا رفعت، أنا صحيح في العادة ماني سلس في البحث
أقعد 4-5 سنين في الكتاب، صحيح
ليطيب ويستوي، ويكون تمام وجاهز
لكن عشر سنين هذا كثير، أنا أبغى أشرب قهوة
وأبغى أدردش مع أصحابي وإخواني
أبغى أتفسح، وأشوف أفلام، وأسمع موسيقى
مش معقولة الواحد كل ليل ونهار
وهو بس في الدرس والخدمة والدراسة
قال لي: هذا موضوع معقد، وأنت لازم يكون عندك صبر
وما تستعجل عليه، والحقيقة هذا الرجل طلع عنده الحق
بدأت كالآتي، بدأت باستراتيجية لها ثلاثة محاور
أولًا، قلت: خلني أشوف الطليان الأرشيف تاعهم على الموضوع
1986 كنت أنا بادئ في الدكتوراة
سألت عن ملفات، تردّدوا شوية، وبعدين طردوني
قالوا لي: بهذا الموضوع ما نقدر نعطيك أي شيء
لأنك أنت من أصل ليبي
والليبيين ما يخلونا ندرس الأرشيف بتاعهم
وبذلك المعاملة بالمثل
رحت لطرابلس، سألت الدكتور «الجراري» في مركز الجهات
قلت له: يا دكتور «الجراري»
صحيح أنتوا ما تخلوا الطليان يدرسوا عن...
هذا هم يهلكونا، ولازم نكون احنا منصفين مع الآخرين
قال لي: هذا كذب أحمر
والطليانية هذه تشوفها اسمها «كلوديا قازيني» تدرس
وفي واحد ثاني طلياني
واحنا بالعكس نعاملهم بكل انفتاح، ومن غير تعقيد
فاتضح أنها أكذوبة
رجعت مرّة أخرى، وأخيرّا اكتشفت الإجابة
في مؤرّخ إيطالي مُحترم جدًّا، ومُعادي للاستعمار
اسمه «أنجلو دلبوكة» من القلائل اللي كتبوا
هم اثنين طليان كتبوا عنها، في واحد اسمه «روشات»
1969 قال: اللي صار في المعتقلات هذه إبادة
ولازم نقول عنها إبادة
في مقال صغير، وبجامعة «تولين»
وبعدين قلت له: أنا عندي مشكلة
أنا أبغى الملفات، ومن غيرها كيف أحقّق؟
ما أقدر أتفلسف من عندي، وأخلق تواريخ، هذا لا يجوز
قال لي: اسمع يا ابني
وعندي رسالة منه، قال لي: لا تضيّع وقتك معهم
هذول كانوا، المشرفين على الأرشيف معظمهم فاشيين سابقين
وأنا قضيت أربعين سنة في هذا الموضوع
واكتشفت أن، إما عبثوا بالملفات، أو أزاحوها من الأرشيف
بعدين سألته سؤال منطقي
قلت له: أيش تبغى أعمل، لو أنك في محلي؟
قال لي: لو أنا منك يا علي، روح إلى شرق ليبيا
ودوّر الأحياء، اللي كان عمرهم من خمس وعشر سنوات
ما بين 1929 و...
الشياب والعجايز كلهم ماتوا هذول خلاص
لكن قال لي: هذول ممكن أطفال، لو أنهم وافقوا يحكوا معك
لو أنا منك أروح هناك، وأقضي معهم وقت
فبدأت، يا عبدالرحمن، من سنة 2000 لغاية 2010
عن طريق أصدقائي ومعارفي في الشرق الليبي
وساعدني أن جدتي هي من شرق ليبيا
هي من عائلة بومريز، اللي هي من كبار عائلات قبيلة الزوية
في أجدابيا وبنغازي والكفرة
فبدأت، ولما قابلتهم في الأول كانوا شكّاكين
قالوا لي: أنت مَن ومن أبوك وأهلك وجدك وأمك، وأنت مِن مَن؟
وفي بعض منهم عرفوني أنا من الأشراف
وعرفوا أني أعرف تاريخهم وعائلاتهم
فبدأوا يرتاحوا لي، وشيئًا فشيئًا بدأوا يوافقوا أنهم يحكوا معي
أيش اللي كان يخيفهم من الحديث عن الموضوع؟
والله هو الموضوع خطير، لسببين
هم عندهم خوف تاريخي للي حصل لأهلهم
في عائلات قُطعت بالكامل
نخبة الاستقلال اللي هم الملك «إدريس»
والقادة، اللي هم قادة الاستقلال الليبي
وهو إنجاز كبير، عملوا واجتهدوا
قالوا: احنا موضوع المرحلة الاستعمارية، مش راح نفتح
احنا مليئين بالمنافي والعنف والرعب والمذابح
وناس طلينت، وناس تعاونت، وناس تواطأت
هذا راح يفتح لنا أبواب لا نستطيع أن نغلقها إطلاقًا
واجتهدوا، أنا لا أقول: أن اجتهادهم كان سيء
أنا أعتقد الاجتهاد له معاييره وحساباته
وله ظروفه
لكن أدّى إلى أن هذه المواضيع
تصبح مسكوت عنها
فارتاحوا لك
فهم قالوا لي: أنت، وبعدين «القذافي» جاء بعنف في 1969
أنتم مات ثلثكم، وللا نصكم؟
وما حد معبركم ولا كتب عنكم، صار ليل ونهار يصرخ في الليبيين
يقولوا: عنده حق في الأول، صدقوه
قالوا: احنا عندنا حقنا
احنا لم نكتب تاريخنا وهذول جاؤوا، وقضوا علينا
وقتلونا، وأخذوا أرضنا، وعملوا فينا فضائع بشعة
لكن بعدين نظام القذافي، وأنا قلتها في الكتاب الأخير
أن بدأ يوظّف الاستعمار الإيطالي والجهاد
لصالح نظامه ولشرعيته فصار في توظيف سياسي
اللي صار خلّى كثير من الليبيين يشكّوا في المسألة
فأنا لازم نحضر هذا السياق، يا عبدالرحمن
لما تعاملت مع الشايبين والعجايز هذول
الشياب اللي في المنطقة الشرقية
كنت واعي وحّساس لمشاعرهم المتضاربة
وقالوا لي: أنت في أمريكا، أيش تعمل فيها؟
وفي الكتاب، وأتمنى، إن شاء الله، أن تقرأها بالعربي
هم عملوا استجواب لي أنا، قبل أن أستجوبهم
وأنا عملت حاجة كانت موفقة جدًّا
قلت: أنهم قاموا باستجوابي ومُساءلتي، ورضيت بها
لأنه فتح باب ما هي أخلاق، وما هو الهدف من البحث العلمي
وكثير من الناس، قالوا لي: هذا أحسن شيء عملته
لأنه فتح موضوع
في العادة الأستاذ يأتي، وهو يعرف، وعنده أدواته
والناس العاديين هذول عبارة عن ناس مرابطة، وعلى قد حالهم وكذا
لا بالعكس، تعاملهم كأنهم عندهم إرادة ومعرفة ورُؤى
وعندهم روح وفهم ووعي، ولا تنظر بشكل أبوي، وللا أستاذي عليهم
فقعدت من 2000 إلى 2010 وأنا أعمل في مقابلات
وفيما بعد مركز «الجهاد» مشكور
أعطوني كل التسجيلات اللي عملوها
وفي ناس صاروا لأن سمعوا عني، ووثقوا فيي
يقولوا: والله لازم يجي عندنا، احنا عندنا أمنا وجدتنا، وللا خالنا
وللا عندنا جدنا هنا، ذاكرته قوية، ولازم تحكي معه
فبدأت المادة تتطور، يا عبدالرحمن، وبدأت
وفي الأخير قرّرت أني
أفدتك بالحديث، أني شفت الأرشيف الإيطالي والإنقليزي
والأرشيف الأمريكي والفرنسي في تونس
والأرشيف المصري، وخاصة الإنقليزي، والمادة عن الموضوع
فعملت زي ما تقول بحث في ثلاث قارات، بثلاث لغات
الشيء الآخر اللي هو أذّيت نفسي فيه
قرأت كل ما كُتب على الإبادة والفاشية باللغة الإيطالية والإنقليزية
لأعُد نفسي
لأني عارف أني أنا مش أبغى أكتب حاجة لليبيين وللعرب بس
أبغى أقدم حاجة معرفة للعالم كله
ليعرفوا الآخرين أن هذا من وجهة نظر عربية إسلامية
من هذه الناحية
فاللي صار أن أخيرًا قررت أعمل الحلقة الأخيرة
وهي، قلت: أنا أبغى أزور المعتقلات الخمسة، معتقلات الموت
واكتشفت ليش أنا قلت أزورها؟
اكتشفت من 110 آلاف
اللي طلعوا أحياء ممكن 30 ألف
تقريبًا ما بين 60 ألف، وربما حتى أكثر من هيك، 70 ألف ماتوا
وماتوا من أيش؟ لما سألتهم، من الجوع والأمراض
الطليان الفاشيين لم يحطوهم في أفران غاز، وللا يقتلوهم
أعطوهم شوية شعير، لأن الشعير احنا عندنا
مش عارف أنتوا في الجزيرة، تحبوه
احنا في ليبيا نحب الشعير كثير، أهلنا
القمح صحيح كويس، لكن الشعير بالنسبة لهم
حتى في أكلات، فيعطوا فيهم الناس شوية شعير أسود
ولما يمرضوا ما يعطوهم لا دواء ولا علاج
فمُعظم الناس ماتوا من الجوع، ومن الأمراض
وحيواناتهم، قُطعانهم اللي جابوها معهم، نَفقت
تقريبًا نص مليون حيوان نفق، يا عبدالرحمن
فالعلاقة العضوية ما بين البني آدم والبيئة والحيوان
هذول الناس، قالوا لي: احنا قبل الطليان، كنا احنا ناس نعمل
نحرث ونزرع ونتاجر، وعندنا حيواناتنا
وعندنا مواطنّا ومعاطنّا، وعندنا كل شيء
احنا ما نبغاهم يطعمونا، احنا نأخذ بالنا من نفسنا
فوجدوا نفسهم ماتوا، في عائلات كاملة 50-60 قُطعت
ماتت في، واللي يُسجّل بشكل إنساني وعميق
معظم الثقافة الليبية، وبالذات البدوية هي شفهية
وثقافة تركّز على الشعر، لأن الشفاهة تتماشى مع
الشعر، والأمثال الشعبية فيهم وزن وموسيقى
فهذه طريقة التعبير الثقافي والحياة اليومية، والتواصل بين الناس
فاكتشفنا أن كثير منهم رجال ونساء، قالوا قصائد
وحُفظت هذه القصائد، من ضمنها المعلقة اللي قلت لك عليها
اللي هي صارت زي الشوكة في ظهر الفاشيين والمستعمرين
اللي هي قصيدة «الفقيه رجب بوحويش المنفي»
العظيمة، عشر صفحات
مابـي مرض غير دار العقيـلة ... وحبس القبيلة
وبعد الجبا من بـلاد الوصيـلة
يقول: أنا مش مريض، يا عبدالرحمن
ولكنني مريض من اللي أشوفه حولي
وهذه القصيدة هائلة، أنا في الكتاب حطيتها في الخلف
وترجمها صديق لي، شاعر ليبي أمريكي
وفي هذه قصيدة أخرى في نفس الوقت
فوجدت أن الشعر الشعبي أو النبطي
كما تقولون أنتوا في الجزيرة العربيّة، هو مصدر مهم
يحتاج أن الواحد ينظره مش بشكل رومانسي وللا يضخم، وللا شيء
تنظره بهدوء
وقعدت سنتين لأفهم أدبيات ولغات وطريقة التعبير
واللهجات داخل اللهجات، لأفهمها كويس
بعدها أخذت آلة التصوير
وكان معي سائق، وأصدقائي دبّروا لي من بنغازي
وذهبت في رحلة لمدة أربعة أيام
من معتقل من المعتقلات الخمسة إلى الآخر
وجدت شيء مخجل، أن الدولة الليبية في العهد الملكي
والعهد «القذافي» استثمرت في بعض أماكن المعتقلات
طُرق وشركات وأراضي وغيره، والشيء أزعجني جدًّا، يا عبدالرحمن
بعدين وصلت إلى معتقلين ما زالوا قائمين
البريقة، والمعتقل الرهيب اللي أسميه أنا زي الـ «هولوكوست» المحرقة
كما هو كامل لم يدمّر
والشيء اللي خلّاني مذعور، وأرتعش المقابر
واحنا نسميه في شمال إفريقيا، الجبابين
أنتوا تقولوا جبابين، جبانة؟
لا
الجبانة هذا اسم مغاربي يعني مقبرة
جبانة المفرد، والجبابين اللي هي مقابر
على مدى البصر، قبور
فرجعت لبنغازي، وأنا والله يا عبدالرحمن لا أبالغ
كنت أرتعش ومذعور من الرعب، شفت الموت عيني عينك
رجعت، وبعدين اكتشفت شيئين آخرين كانوا مهمين في هذا التحقيق
اللي أنا 80% ما كنت أعرفه
حصّلت سنة 2012 على أرشيف الجنرال الدموي
اللي هو خلف المعتقلات، أنا سميتها إبادة
وممكن تسألني تقول لي: ليش سميتها إبادة؟
ليش سميتها؟
لسببين، أبو نظرية الإبادة الحديثة بعد الحرب العالمية الثانية
«رفائيل ليمكين» هذا فقيه وعالم قانوني بولندي
كان أشرف على مؤتمر للأمم المتحدة ضد الإبادة
الحلفاء كان من حقهم، كان عندهم أن يورّوا بشاعة النازية وغيره
ولسبب وجيه، فقال: أن الإبادة لازم نحددها بشكل قانوني، ونضبطها
مش كل واحد صار له شيء مشكلة، تقول هذا إبادة
قال: أولًا لازم يكون في النية، (Intentionality) باللغة الإنقليزية
ثانيًا تحطيم أوجه الحياة العضوية والثقافية والاقتصادية والاجتماعية
وإبدالها بالمستعمر أو بالمهيمن
أنا دورت، لقيت رسائل في الأرشيف الإيطالي
اللي تقول: والله احنا هدفنا أن نخضع هؤلاء المسلمين والعرب
حتى لو أدّى إلى القضاء عليهم كلهم
لأن مستقبل الأمة الإيطالية هو اللي على المحك، وهذا أهم شيء
وراني النية، ولقيت رسائل أخرى تؤكّد هذا
وبعدين عدد الموتى، يا عبدالرحمن، ثلثينهم ماتوا
ثلثين الناس من 110 ألف، 60-70 ألف ماتوا بالمعتقلات
بشكل محدد، ولما سألت
نقول لهم: أيش صار يا عمتي وعمي؟
يقولوا لي: يا ابني احنا قطعنا، اللي هو مُتنا باللهجة البدوية الليبية
قطعنا من الشر والمرض
فاللي صار أني أصريت أن اسم الشر يكون في عنوان الكتاب
وبذلك سميته «الإبادة الجماعية في ليبيا، شر»
وأي عربي راح يفهم كلمة الشر
لكن بالنسبة للمعتقلين، يا عبدالرحمن
تعني أن الموت الجماعي في المعتقلات الفاشيّة من الجوع والمرض
المفروض عليهم، ونفق حيواناتهم، هذا الجانب مهم
كثير من العرب يقفزوا على الأشياء هذه، هذا مهم جدًّا
لأن كانوا ينظروا للحيوان خاصة، المشكلة في الجزيرة العربيّة
عندنا ناسنا في ليبيا بالذات ناس البادية وكذا
الإبل هي زي الإنسان
أنا أذكر أن الروائي الليبي العبقري «إبراهيم الكوني»
عنده رواية اسمها «التبر» على طارق إنسان بدوي، وجمل مَهَري
هذا نوع من الإبل في ليبيا، نقول: المهاري، والمفرد
ومحبتهم وصداقتهم مع بعضهم
فتكتشف أن علاقاتهم بالحيوان هي علاقة إنسانية
مختلفة على قضية أن الحيوان هو من أجل البني آدم
وتقتل، وتأكل منه وتدمرهم، زي ما دمروا الحيوانات في ليبيا
وزي ما دمروا في أمريكا في إبادة السكان الأصليين
حيوان، ملايين الجواميس في أمريكا
فجاءت إلى هذه الفكرة، قلت: هذا إبادة جماعية
بناءً على الشروط اللي وضعها «رفائيل ليمكين»
في شيئين آخرين كملوا حلقة التحقيق
اللي أخذ فترة طويلة، عقد تقريبًا وخمس سنوات بعدها
من غربلة، وتمحيص ما هو صحيح، وما هو غير صحيح
ما هو الأكيد، وما هو غير الأكيد
خمسة عشر سنة؟
عشر سنوات من الدراسة الميدانيّة والأرشيفيّة
وخمس سنوات من البحث والتمحيص
التمحيص، خمسة عشر سنة
بعدين ربّك ابتسم لي، يمكن الأشراف بركتهم لاحقتني في أمريكا
في 2012 استطعت الحصول على ملفات الجنرال الدموي
«قراتسياني» اللي أشرف على المعتقلات والإبادة
ست كرتونات، وكأن عندنا كنز الدنيا، يا عبدالرحمن
كنت أنظر لهم، وأقول: أنا خلاص قريب وصلت الجنة
ربك رحمني، وكريم معي
فقرأتها بتأنّي، وكانت مرعبة ومتعجرفة
وفيها تفاصيل مهمة على أماكن أخرى
ولكن فيها أيضًا كذب وتدليس
مثل؟
هذا مهم، الحلقة الأخيرة في الاكتشاف، وهذا بالتحقيق
وأنا لم أكن أدري أي شيء عنه
كنت مرّة أقرأ في مجلة باللغة العربيّة أصدرها صحفي ليبي مدعوم
زي ما تقول، هي إيطاليا لم تُمانع بعد التاريخ الدموي
أن أعطى الصحفي الليبي الحق
في إصدار مجلة اسمها «ليبيا المصوّرة»
اسمه «فخري المحيشي» رجل حصيف
كان يعطي الأشياء اللي يبغوها الطليان
وكان في نفس الوقت يعطي صورة ومساحة للشعراء والأدباء، الأخبار
وأنا أقرأ في مجلدات «ليبيا المصورة»
وجدت واحد من عتاة القادة النازيين «قورينق»
هذا من أقرب الناس إلى هتلر، وكان رئيس السلاح الجوي
ومن القادة الكبار في النازية
وجدت صورته في طرابلس، أيام الحكم الإيطالي
قلت: المصيبة هذا أيش يعمل؟
قلت: علي خلّيك حصيف وهادي، لا تقفز على الواقع، شوف
هذا يمكن مُجرد مصادفة عجيبة
أنا للأسف الشديد، أنا أقرأ بالفرنسي، وأعرف بالإيطالية جيدًا
ولكن الألماني لا أقرأ به، يا عبدالرحمن
فاللي صار أني سألت بعض زملاء لي عن طريق النت
قلت لهم: في أحد يشتغل على المراسلات النازية الفاشية
والعلاقات مع المستعمرات؟
ففي صديق قال لي: في أستاذ ومؤرخ ألماني شاب محترم جدًّا
يدرّس في إيرلندا اسمه «باتريك»
لا أذكر الآن اسم، على أية حال
المهم فيه أن أرسلت له بريد الكتروني
وقلت له: أنا فلان الفلاني، أبغى أتاكد منك إذا كان في أي معلومات
أو هل في أي أشياء أخرى، أنا على غير دراية بها
فيما يتعلق باهتمام القادة النازيين بتجربة المعتقلات
وتوطين الفقراء والفلّاحين الطليان في ليبيا
وهنا جاءت المفاجأة، يا عبدالرحمن
أيش كانت؟
قال لي: لا، هذا جزء من قطرة في تيار كبير
قال لي: أن الحقيقة
القادة النازيين لم يكن معجبين بالتجربة البريطانية أو الفرنسية
كانوا معجبين بالتجربة الإيطالية
واعتقدوا أن أهم شيء عملوه الطليان
أنهم فرّغوا السكان من شرق ليبيا بسبب المعتقلات
وهذا شبيه باهتمامهم بتوطين 15 مليون ألماني في شرق أوربا
كمستعمرات، كفضاء حيوي لقدام
فسيدي العزيز، بعدين قلت له: ممكن تعطيني مصادر؟
بعث لي خمس دراسات معمّقة
واكتشفت شيء مذهل، أن احنا العرب
وحتى الدراسات اللي تركّز على المركزية الأوربيّة
المحرقة أنها أهم شيء، وأن الأشياء الأخرى عبارة عن ضحايا حروب
زي ما يقول بعض الأساتذة الأمريكان، ضباب الحرب
هذه تصير في الحروب، هذه ما تلوم أحد عليها
تصير في كل الحروب والفضائع
لما بعث لي، اكتشفت أن في شيء أكبر
وهو أن قُبيل المحرقة هذا كان عامل مهم
أن فجأة احنا العرب والمسلمين في الحالة الليبية
الفاشيّة كانت جزء من التجربة الليبية
اللي هي شبيهة بالمحرقة اليهودية
وتعطي نوع من الترابط والتأثير المتبادل
رجعت بعدين إلى أستاذة فيلسوفة
أهم فيلسوفة مُعاصر ألمانيّة أمريكية هي «حنة آرنت»
اللي هي كتبت كتاب مُهم جدًّا «أوصول الشمولية»
وقالت: أن المحرقة اليهوديّة
وهي كانت من ضحايا النازية، وهاجرت لأمريكا
قالت: أن لتعرف المحرقة
لا بد أن تدرس بعمق الفضائع الألمانية والفرنسية
في إفريقيا، بالذات في الكونقو، اللي هو قتل نحو 10 مليون فيها
كونقو الحالية هذه
وقالت: أن المحرقة، المؤرخين والعلماء الأوربيين والغربيين
يجب أن يهتموا بالفضائع اللي هي سبقت المحرقة
اللي هي الكونقو
وبعدين الهيريرو في ناميبيا، بما يسمى ناميبيا الآن
وأنا لأني اكتشفت حاجة رهيبة جدًّا
قلت: أن الحالة الليبية، الحالات الثلاثة
الحالة الجزائرية أيضًا عنيفة ومرعبة
لكن علاقتها بالمحرقة
الآن أنا أطرح ليس إعادة كتابة المعتقلات الفاشية
وتاريخها المنسي والمخفي
أنا الآن حاولت أن أكتب هذا الكتاب لإعادة كتابة تاريخ الفاشية
والإبادة في المحرقة اليهوديّة نفسها، والضحايا الـ 5 ملايين الآخرين
اللي هم قتلوا سواءً الغجر والكاثوليكيين والاشتراكيين
والمثليين، والمعاقين اللي قضوا عليهم
وهذا الآن خالق ضجّة كبيرة ليس فقط في أمريكا
ولكن أيضًا في أوربا
بدأت الكتاب، يُطرح على أنه مدرسة جديدة
في إعادة التفكير في الإبادة
بربط الإبادة في أوربا بالإبادة اللي صارت في إفريقيا
وبما فيها الحالة الليبية اللي هي العربيّة، الغريبة شوية
لكن مجهولة يا عبدالرحمن
أول مرّة أسمع بها
مش أنت بس، أقول لك على حاجة أخرى، راح تذهل
بعدما نشرت كتابي «الأصوات المهمشة»
دعتني الجامعات العريقة في أمريكا
في «هارفارد» و«ييل» و«بيركلي» و«يو سي إل إيه»
في «كولومبيا» ويا سيدي، في «براون»
و«ييل» عندها مركز «دراسات الإبادة المقارن»
مركز «دراسات حالات الإبادة المقارنة أو المقارن»
فأنا صارت عندي عادة، مش مشاكسة، لكن حبيت أعرف
أقول لهم: أحد يعرف على المعتقلات الفاشية في ليبيا؟
يقولوا لي: «بروفيسور أحميدة» هل كان في معتقلات؟
وكانوا لطيفين ومنفتحين، يا عبدالرحمن
ما كانوا متأفّفين، وللا شيء
لكن اكتشفت شيء رهيب
أن الطليان، وفشل الدراسات الليبية في أن تكتب عليها
لا العرب عارفين عنها، ولا الأجانب
لأنها نجحت عملية التستر، والاسّكات
فهذا أدّى إلى أن، زائد أكد لي
طرح علي سؤال جديد، وهو
مش بس لازم نحقق بشكل قانوني وحصيف ومنضبط
على المعتقلات وتاريخها وتأثيراتها
ولكن أيضًا سألت نفسي سؤال جديد
قلت: من المسؤول عن الاسكات في الدراسات الغربية والأوربيّة
والدراسات ما بعد الاستعمار؟
هل هو بسبب عفوي، ومن غير نية
وللا في عوامل أدّت إلى اسكات وردم
وإخفاء هذا التاريخ الدموي العنيف؟
اكتشفت أن في إيطاليا للآن ليس فقط لا يدرّسوا الموضوع هذا
في ثلاثة وأربعة مؤرخين مهمين، والآخرين لا يهتموا بالموضوع إطلاقًا
ثانيًا «قراتسياني» في مدينته بانين له تمثال، دليل على التمجيد
هذا الرجل الدموي اللي يديه ملطخة بالدماء، هذا الجنرال
وأخوي عبدالرحمن، لأن عكس النازية
النازية زعمائها وقادتها صارت لهم محاكمة ضد الإنسانية وجرائم
لم يحدث هذا للجرائم الإيطالية للمعتقلات وغيرها
والاعتذار اللي حصل عليه «القذافي» هو مهم
حتى الجزائريين لم يحصلوا عليه، كان شوي غامض
ليه؟
اعتذار وكذا، ولكن لم يفصّل في أيش صار وكذا
وجاء «برلسكوني» وهو رجل أعمال
قبّل إيده، وحب على رأسه وخشمه
وقال: خلاص أنا فتحت عكّا، أنا هزمت الاستعمار وكذا
فكان فيه كلفة شوية، وحتى التعويض كان لا يليق بالناس
لأني أنا صرت بعدما سمعت من الناس
اللي كانوا في المعتقلات الأحياء، النساء والرجال
وخاصة أحكي لك على قصة، للآن تُدمي قلبي
سيدة ليبية عجوز في الثمانينيات، ولكن ذاكرتها ممتازة
كانت تبكي، وتغني لي في نفس الوقت
تقول لي: يا ولدي، اللي صار لنا ما صار لأحد
قلت لها: صار لناس أخرى. استمعت لها احترامًا وتبجيلًا لها
وتغني شوية، وتبكي لي شوية
واحد أعطاني، قصدي عشان أوريك كيف أنا أصرت الآن
في الأول كنت مُحايد ومنضبط
ولا بد من العلم والمعرفة وعدم
لكن بعدين قلت: الكتاب لازم يُكتب من وجهة نظر هؤلاء الناس
اللي ما عندهم أي تاريخ، وإنكار أن لهم تاريخ أصلًا
ولهم أصوات وإرادة فاعلة
فصارت الآن فكرة الكتاب
بعد الخمس سنوات هذه، صرت أكتب
وكتبته، ومش بشكل عفوي، وللا نيتي
أنا كتبته، الناس اللي كانوا يرووا لي روايات شفهية
واللي محّقتها تمامًا، وصلت اللي عندي تقريبًا نحو 300 مقابلة
اللي عطوها لي الناس، واللي أنا عملتها بنفسي
وجدت الآتي، أن الكتاب أبغاه أن يكون فيه تشويق للقارئ
لأن الموضوع ثقيل، ومُحبط القلب، وهَم وغَم
فقلت: خليني، والله من غير وعي، يا عبدالرحمن
كتبته كقصة، قصة جهاد لاكتشاف الحقيقة، وصار كله
قالوا لي الناس الحقيقة رغم أنه مزعج، لكن ما تقدر تحطها
لازم تكمله، لأنه زي الرواية، وبعدين صديق لي
عزيز جدًّا، وهو كاتب ليبي محترم
قال لي: قعدت أنبّش، أيش قصته علي هذا، من أين جاه؟
بعدين قال لي: اكتشفت أن أنت بدأت في الثانوي بالأدب
كنت علاقتك بالأدب قوية
قلت: هذا صحيح، لكن عندما كان تنغمس وتتعمق وتفهم
طريقة الثقافة العربيّة الشفاهية في الكلام والرواية
أنت تصير راوية، من غير ما تشعر
صحيح
فالكتاب تطور من غير أن أقول: لازم أكتبه بالصورة هذه
وإلا المعلومة عندي
إطلاقًا، 80% من هذا الكتاب اكتشفته عن طريق التحقيق
وكنت دائمًا أركّز على هذه الكلمة، يا عبدالرحمن
قلت: أنا أحقّق في جريمة جماعية، وأنت كمحقق موضوعي ومنصف
تبحث عن الحقيقة
وبذلك اضبط روحك، خليك منضبط
وكون حصيف مع الدليل والقرائن والحقائق
ولكن في نفس الوقت، لما دليل أو موضوع
دُمّر، وللا ألغي، وللا أخفي، من حقّك أنت كباحث
أنت تقول: نفترض هذه الصورة أو الطريقة موجودة
وبعدين قلت: مش راح أكتبه بس لليبيين والعرب والمسلمين
أنا أبغى أكتبه للعالم، والحالة الليبية لن تكن فريدة أو وحيدة
هي جزء من حالات أخرى في أوربا وإفريقيا والعالم نفسه
وبدأت، وأنهيت الكتاب بطريقة مشاكسة لزملائي الأمريكان
قلت: أنا الآن عايش في أمريكا، وأستاذ أمريكي
كيف كانت صورة هذها الموضوع بالنسبة للثقافة والفكر
بالجامعات الأمريكيّة؟
فاخترت ثلاثة مواضيع للتحقيق فيها
«نيويورك تايمز» قرأت كل المقالات من 1911-1943 عن الموضوع
ولقيت نحو خمس أو ست مقالات، كانت فضيحة
كلها تمجّد الاستعمار الإيطالي، ومنحازة له
بعدين الأرشيف الأمريكي في وزارة الخارجية، فيه كانت معلومات مهمة
وكان في دبلوماسي أمريكي في روما
قُنصل كان جيد، وموقفه جيد جدًّا في الموضوع
بعدين يا سيدي العزيز، في مجلة أمريكية شعبية
يمكن سامع بها، اسمها مجلة «ناشيونال جيوقرافيك»
قديمة من بداية القرن العشرين
فشفت كيف نظرة هذه المجلة على العالم المستَعمر
أو العالم الغير أوربي
وجدت فيها تحقيقات في غاية الظرافة، بعدها أفلام هوليوود
لأن في العالم العربي دائمًا احنا نفصل التخصصات
وهذه أعتقد كارثة علينا الآن
لازم ننظر إلى تداخل التخصصات مع بعضها
وهذا يعطينا رُؤى أشمل وأعمق
وأخيرًا نظرت إلى أساتذة التاريخ والعلوم السياسية
اللي كتبوا على الفاشية الإيطالية، فكانت فضيحة
كانت كلها تتماشى بشكل خفيف مع السردية الفاشية والإيطالية
واكتشفت أن في تركيز على شيئين
هذا اكتشاف أن الجدل المهيمن، وهو أن هناك فاشية نازية وحشية
لأن الشعب الألماني قاسي وعنيف، ولهذا أدّى إلى مذابح وإبادة
الشعب الإيطالي بتاعين ثقافة وأوبرا وبيتزا وإسباقيتي
ودمهم خفيف وشرق وسطيين
مش معقولة يديروا للشيء هذا، غير معقول
زائد أنهم كانوا كويسين مع إخواننا وأخواتنا اليهود
وبذلك حتى الأستاذة العظيمة اللي أنا أحبها جيدًا «حنة آرنت»
قالت: لم يكن هناك سؤال معاداة السامية في إيطاليا
ما تعرف عن موضوع ليبيا
فاللي صار بعدها واضح أن بالمقابل
في أطروحات الإبادة في أدبيات الإبادة
اللي هي، يا عبدالرحمن، الكتابات على الإبادة والمحرقة
هي كتابات في الأدبيات الفلسفية والفنية، والنظرية الغربية، مهيمنة
هذا الموضوع الأثير في الدراسات
آلاف الكتب والمعارض والمتاحف والنصب التذكارية
في كل مكان، فالموضوع مهيمن
اضطريت أزور مُتحف المحرقة
ويمكن أكون المسلم والعربي الوحيد اللي كان موجود هناك
بغيت أشوف أيش عملوا
وكنت بقول لهم في نفسي، احنا في الموقف هذا
احنا وأنتم في الهوا سوا، في الهم سوا
فهناك النازية والثقافة الألمانية المهيمنة، وتؤدي إلى الإبادة
وهناك فاشية حميدة أقل شرًا
وهذا التماثل والتفكير مهيمن بطريقة لا تتصورها
فأنا وجدت نفسي، أني لازم أشاكس، وأدمّر هذه الأسطورة
وأعتقد وأتمنى، يكون الواحد يعتقد شيء
لكن أتمنى أن هذا الكتاب يُثير جدل هم لم يتعودوا عليه
وأتمنى في العالم العربي أن الموضوع هذا
الكتاب اللي أرهقني وأنهكني، وهلك حيلي
أن الناس تقرأ خلال العشر سنوات الأخيرة تستوعبه وتناقشه
ويمكن تستوعب أنه هو مش على بس المعتقلات اللي صارت 1929
لا، هو صراع على الذاكرة والصمت
وأن هذا لنا احنا يمكن يعطينا مفاتيح لإعادة كتابة
مش تاريخ الدولة بس، احنا نحتاج تاريخ مجتمعاتنا
وهذا يبدوا لي رغم أن في دراسات جيّدة على البلدان العربيّة كثيرة
لكن يمكن يكون هو طريقة طازجة وجديدة، وأجندة للبحث العلمي
بأسئلة جديدة يمكن في القرن هذا أن احنا كعرب بالذات
اللي مهتمين في فهم مجتمعاتنا وتداخلاتها وتاريخها
مش تاريخ الماضي في الماضي، يا عبدالرحمن
أنا أسميه تاريخ الحاضر، يا عبدالرحمن
في تاريخ تقليدي، اللي هو تاريخ السنوات والأسامي والشخصيات
وفي تاريخ آخر أكثر تعقيدًا، وأهميّة لنا
اللي هو أصول وجذور، كيف بدأت هذه الصراعات
وكيف استمرّ الصراع عليها حتى الآن
فالكتاب، حاولت أطبق هذا على كتابي
فحاولت أنظر لـ 1929 وبعدين المرحلة الاستعمارية
الاستقلال ومرحلة سبتمبر و«القذافي»
والآن حتى عودة الرموز التاريخية في الجدل القائم
وأنا أعتقد هذا يمكن ليس حالة ليبية محدودة
ولكن ربما يعطينا أسئلة ورؤى جديدة
على إعادة كتابة التاريخ الحاضر في العالم العربي كله
الله يعطيك العافية، مثل هذه المجهودات وهذا البحث
هو اللي يعطي هذه الروح الجديدة في البحث
وحتى كيف ترى العالم من خلال زاويتك
مو لازم أن كيف يرى الآخر، فأحسها مهم
وكل الكتب والأشياء اللي ذكرتها بتكون في نشرة هذه الحلقة
بإذن الله
أنا بأخذ الحين تواريخ سريعة
تفضل
بحيث احنا مرينا بالإبادة
وبنتقل إلى 1943 انتهاء الاستعمار الإيطالي
نعم، والحلفاء زحفوا بعد حرب العالمين
زحفوا، وهزموا الجيوش الألمانية والإيطالية
أخذوا برقة والمنطقة الغربية
طرابلس
نعم، والفرنسيين جاؤوا من تشاد، وأخذوا فزان
ففزان صارت تحت الاستعمار؟
الإدارة الفرنسية
هم في العادة يعطوا فيها اسم لطيف، إدارة
الإداره البريطانية والفرنسية
التقسيم هذا، هو إدارة بس أنه استعمار؟
نقدر نسميه احنا استعمار؟
التمييز بين الاثنين غائم
لكن أعتقد أن الفرنسيين كان دايمًا عندهم حُلم، أن فزان تستقل
وحاولوا يعرضوا على الباي «أحمد سيف النصر»
القائد والمجاهد الكبير، ورفض أنه يعطوه
وطلعوا له طوابع وكذا، وبنوا مدينة سبها
وكان المنهج التعليمي هو الفرنسي من الجزائر
حتى بعض الشباب الصغار، كانوا يدرسوا فيهم في امتحانات
يأخذوا امتحانات في الجزائر في النظام الفرنسي
وللآن بعد سقوط نظام سبتمبر
الفرنسيين الآن حاولوا يعودوا بقوة إلى فزان، ويلعبوا دور أكبر
لأن يعتقدوا أن نظام «القذافي» أزاحهم من جزء مهم من ليبيا
ويعتقدوا أنهم جزء منها
ولهذا «ساركوزي» وعلاقته شائكة مع «القذافي»
دخل بقوة في ضرب النيتو للجيش الليبي ولنظام «القذافي»
الآن كان هذه الدولتين أخذت هذه الأقاليم الثلاثة؟
نعم
اختلف شيء في هذه الفترة إلى الاستقلال 1951؟
والله هذه المرحلة تحتاج دراسة أعمق، لكن الذي أعرفه عنها
أن الإدارة البريطانية عملت بالتنسيق مع القيادات
السّيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
والقيادات الطرابلسية في إعادة بعد مرحلة دموية وحروب
وتدمير بنغازي ثلاث أو أربع مرات
بدأوا في بناء البنية التحتية في التعليم والإدارة
وفي عودة المنفيين والمهاجرين
في أشياء إيجابية كثيرة حصلت في ليبيا
ولكن كانت الضغوطات والمُماحكات بيناتهم
أيش نعمل بليبيا، زي ما حكيت لك في بداية حديثنا
اتفاق القيادة الليبية في الغرب بالذات
مع الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي» كان مهم
لأن هو التوافق اللي برأيي خلق استقلال ليبيا
ورفض السيد «أحمد سيف النصر» للاستقلال أو الانفصال بفزان
وقبل إمارة السّيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
والقيادات الطرابلسية بدأت في التأجيج
وتعبئة الناس ضد مشروع التقسيم
اللي هو كان مشروع «بيفن سفورزا» اللي حكينا عنه من قبل
هذه العوامل أعتقد أدّت إلى إفشال مشاريع التقسيم في ليبيا
ودعمّت مشروع الاستقلال، وخاصة هو كان مشروع توافقي
لأن السّيد «إدريس» صار ملك ليبيا
ولخلق توازن بين الأقاليم الثلاثة، عملوا شيء طبيعي
نظام فدرالي، لكن دستوري في مجلس الشيوخ والنواب
وكانت في مؤسسات بدعم الأمم المتحدة
اللي بعثت مندوب اسمه «أدريان بيلت»
ساعد الليبيين في المسألة هذه، وعملوا دستور
أنا أعتقد، والليبيين يتفقوا معي فيه كثير
كان دستور مُحترم بمقاييس الخمسينيات والستينيات
ممتاز
الآن شيء آخر، لكن هذيك الفترة مهمة
وهناك ناس لحتى الآن يدعون إلى عودة الدستور السابق
اللي هو المملكة الليبية المتحدة الفدرالي؟
نعم
في الآن جدل كبير، ولم يحسم حتى الآن
هناك ناس يدعون للنظام الفدرالي لأسباب جهويّة
وأسباب ما يسموه بالتهميش في شرق ليبيا، برقة
وهناك ناس يقولون أن «القذافي» من أكثر أخطاء نظامه
أنه لم يبنى مؤسسات أو يؤدي إلى كتابة دستور جديد
وبذلك عندنا الدستور عظيم ومُهم
اللي هو نقّح في الـ 1963 صارت عملية تنقيح وتعديل
يقولوا: احنا نعوله إليه
ليبيين آخرين، يقولوا: لا، هذا كان مهم في ذيك الفترة
لكن ممكن في جوانب نأخذه منها
لكن احنا نحتاج إلى إعادة كتابة دستور جديد
كان في هيئة دستورية منتخبة بعد 2012
للأسف أنا مع كل احترامي لهم، لا أعتقد أن في فترة الحروب الأهلية
وعدم الاستقرار، الوقت مناسب أنك تكتب دستور
لكتابة دستور، أبي ارجع إلى 1951 الاستقلال
أيش دفع ليبيا أنها تستقل قبل تونس والجزائر
رغم أنها كانت أكثر فقرًا؟
حركة ليبية قوية، الاستقلالية
سواءً المنفيين الليبيين اللي كانوا يطالبوا بشكل مُستمر
ولعبوا دور سياسي وإعلامي مهم للمطالبة بالاستقلال
وإشعال واستمرارية القضية الليبية في حق تقرير المصير
تحالف الأمير «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
مع قيادة الحلفاء وبالذات الإنقليز
لعب دور، كثير من الليبيين يختلفوا مع هذا
لكن لا بد من تختلف معه
كان له دور أنه وجد حليف خارجي في المسألة
والإنقليز كانت عندهم، مش حبًا في الملك «إدريس»
كانوا يبغوا بعد القلاقل في مصر
يبحثوا كانوا عن أمن واستقرار من وجهة نظرهم لشرق ليبيا
على وجودهم في مصر، وبذلك كان التحالف بالنسبة لهم هذا مهم
فهم مش حبًا في عيون الليبيين
وللا السيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
كانوا يبغوا استقرار وتحالف استراتيجي
يضمن وجودهم في مصر
وقناة السويس بالنسبة لهم هذه قضية محورية
بالنسبة لوجود الإمبراطورية البريطانية بشكل عام
الشيء الآخر، يا عبدالرحمن
بالإضافة إلى نضال المهاجرين والمنفيين، التحالف السياسي
والحلقة الأخيرة اتفاق الليبيين على الاستقلال ككيان موحد
كما كانت ولاية طرابلس الغرب، والدولة القرمانلية
كما كان الكيان من قبل في القرون الأولى
فظهور وعي سياسي ما بين شرائح عديدة
في المناطق الثلاث هذه، الجادة الثلاث
ساعد في إعطاء القضية الليبية، وحصل توافق
الحلفاء، في فترة النضال للشعوب المستعمرّة من أجل الاستقلال
وجدوا أنهم الأنسب أن يوافقوا على نظام إلى حد كبير متحالف معهم
وبذلك وجدوا أن هذه فكرة جيدة، واستوعبوها
والقيادة الأمريكيّة كانت تلعب أن الأوربيين
هؤلاء سيئي السمعة، وتولتهم سيدة
وتاريخهم لأنهم استعمروا الشعوب، احنا غير
وهذا كيف صار؟
في الأول كان التحالف مع بريطانيا، لكن بعدين صار مع أمريكا
واكتشاف النفط كان محوري
ثورة 23 يوليو في مصر، خوّفهم أكثر
وخلّاهم يهتموا باستقرار واستمرارية المملكة الليبية
ولكن المملكة الليبية إلى حد كبير، وهذا شيء لازم نعترف بها
كانت مملكة دستورية تحديثية، التعليم فيها قفز قفزات نوعية
وكانت فيها إلى حد كبير، لا أقول: نظام ديمقراطي
لكن مجلس شيوخ، ومجلس نواب مُنتخب
وكان فيها مش صحافة مثلًا، في حد قريب من المساحة
ولهذا ليبيا في نهاية الستينيات
كانت دولة عربية قفزت قفزات نوعية في التعليم والتحديث
وكانت طرابلس من أجمل مدن البحر المتوسط
فهذه الجوانب الإيجابية
في جوانب سلبيات، لازم الواحد يذكرها القواعد وعدم فهم التغيرات
سيطرة الأعيان والفئات العليا للمجتمع على الاقتصاد والدولة
في أشياء أخرى ممكن الواحد يأخذها معه
لكن لا بد من الإنصاف لجيل الاستقلال
ولكن من غير، أنا أتفق مع الإنصاف والموضوعية
لأنها فترة كانت مزدهرة وإيجابية وتحديثية
لكن يجب أن لا ننظر لها من ناحية رومانسية أو مثالية
لأنها كانت فيها عيوب وإشكاليات مؤسساتية
وخيارات أدّت إلى استمرارها فيما بعد، حتى بعد 1969
هل كان استقلال حقيقي أم صوري؟
أنا أعتقد كان استقلال حقيقي، ولكن مليء بالتناقضات
أنا أجبتك إجابة، أنت تحاول تلخبطني، لخبطتك يا عبدالرحمن
عفوًا أنا لا أريد أن أكون فهلوي معك
قصدت أن بعد مرحلة الاستعمار الاستيطاني الإبادي العنيف
حتى رغم أن فيه نواقص كان إنجاز
أنا بالنسبة لي ولدت بعد الاستقلال
ولكن تعلمت في دولة ليبيا الحديثة
والسبعينيات فيما بعدها، بعهد سبتمبر
ولهذا الجيل اللي قبلي، واللي بعدي
احنا هذا بالنسبة لنا كان إنجاز كبير
وكانوا الليبيين فخورين أن صارت لهم دولة المملكة الليبية
أنا أسميها دولة الاستقلال
وأعتقد من الناحية هذه هو إنجاز، وخاصة التوافق
اللي أعتبره أكثر شيء أنجزوه
أكثر إنجاز
لكن هناك مشاكل
صحيح
القواعد الأجنبية، التركيز النخبوي، وعدم السماح بالأحزاب
عدم التسامح مع قيادات المعارضة
السيد «بشير السعداوي» سُفّر من ليبيا
وأخذوا منه جنسيته، وانتهى أنه مات في المنفى
ففي جوانب، لهذا قلت لك: أنه كان إنجاز، ولكن مليء بالتناقضات
هذا ما أعنيه بالتناقضات
أيش قصة انقلاب 1961؟
1961 مو حصل انقلاب اللي طالب فيهم الملك «إدريس»
أن يأخذوا عقوبات، لكن صارت عقوبات مخفّفة
في بعضهم يقول: أن انقلاب 1961
أنت تقصد اللي هو
محاولة انقلاب
محاولة اغتيال «إبراهيم الشلحي»
إي
هو اغتيال للسّيد «إبراهيم الشلحي»
وهو مستشار الملك «محمد إدريس السنوسي» الله يرحمه
السيد «إبراهيم الشلحي» يعرفه من طفولته
وكان مُستشاره، وذراعه اليمنى
كان في صراع داخل الأسرة الحاكمة
ما بين أحفاد السّيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي»
اللي هو مات عندكم في الحجاز، تتذكر هو نُفي
ففي نوع من التوتر بين جناحي الأسرة السنوسية
السّيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي» اللي هو كان أكثر اعتدالًا
وأكثر براغماتيةً في السياسة والتعاون مع القوى الدولية والواقع
ولازم ننصف السيد «محمد إدريس السنوسي»
لأنه كان يقود حركة عسكرية، وهُزمت
وبذلك حتى أدواته، وقدرته على التفاوض كانت محدودة
زي ما قلت أنا في كتابي الأول
لكن كانت في هناك نوع من التوتر، ما بين جناح
وكانوا يعتقدوا أن «آل الشلحي»
اللي هم لصقاء بالملك «إدريس»
مستوحدين على الملك، وأنه مغبوبين
فكان في نوع من التوتر
وانتهى باغتيال مستشار الملك السّيد «إبراهيم الشلحي»
والملك «إدريس» غضب من جناح وأحفاد وأبناء وبنات
السّيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي»
وأنفاهم في واحات بعيدة في ليبيا
هل ساهم بأي شكل من الأشكال في تهيأة الجو لاقلاب «القذافي»؟
هذا سؤال وجيه، ولم أفكر فيه من قبل
يحتاج إلى نوع من التمحيص والتفكير فيه
لكن أعتقد ليس عجيبًا أن في بيان الانقلاب أو ثورة
صارت بعد ثورة الفاتح، كما يقول أصحابها
يا أبناء المدن والبادية، وأبناء المدن العريقة
يا أحفاد «أحمد الشريف» و«عمر المختار»
أنا أبيك تركز معي يا عبدالرحمن
ذكر السيد «أحمد الشريف السنوسي»
وذكر سيد شيخ الشهداء «عمر المختار»
وهذا نوع، هو اضطهد العائلة السنسوية
كما اضطهد عائلة «سيف النصر» للأسف الشديد
وكثير من النخب الأولى، وانتقم منهم كثيرًا
لكن هو بحاول يقول: أنا مع المجاهدين، وسليل المجاهدين، وامتداد لهم
فتجد تعقيدات، والتوظيف الرمزي للقيادات التاريخية
الليبيين حتى هذا اليوم، يا عبدالرحمن
يتكلمون على الحاضر من خلال الكلام على الماضي
على المرحلة الاستعمارية والجهاد
أنا أزعم هذا، وهذا شيء طبيعي
لأنك أنت تحكي على فترة التكوين، وفترة عنيفة
ولكن فترة فيها تحوّلات وإبادة وعنف ومقاومة
وتواطؤ وتعاون وهكذا
بس هذا الرابط ما بين الاغتيال و«القذافي»
ممتاز، كيف نجح «القذافي» في انقلابه؟
أيش العوامل اللي ساعدته؟
هل كانت في عوامل خارجية وداخلية؟
هذا يحتاج إلى دراسات عميقة
في عندنا بعض الدراسات، ولكن ليس بالعمق
قد تستغرب ليس هناك دراسة وافية على المسائل هذه
في كتب أيديولوجية معه أو ضده
لكن باجتهادي
وأنا هذا موضوع ربما يحتاج مني أكثر من التفكير والتدقيق والتمحيص
هناك عوامل ساعدت «القذافي»
النظام الملكي كان ناجح من ناحية التحديثية والرفاهية
ومن ناحية التعليم، واستقلال ليبيا
ولكن خفوته وسكوته عن المرحلة الاستعمارية، والقواعد
في عالم عربي يموج بالحركات المضادة للاستعمار
و«عبد الناصر» والقومية العربيّة
وسؤال القضية الفلسطينية، واستقلال الجزائر 1962
اللي ليبيا لعبت فيها دور كبير أهلي وسياسي
خلّى النظام في حالة دفاع
وأعتقد هذا مجرد حدس، وليس عندي أي دليل
نظام ركّز ليس على الجيش والشرطة، القوة المتحركة
كانت قوات الشرطة أكثر تسليحًا
بعدد مساوي بالجيش
الجيش كان صغير، وليس بالحجم الكبير
والجيش كان مفتوح لفئات عديدة من الشعب
«القذافي» كان عنده سواءً نتفق معه أو نختلف
كان قائد كاريزماتي، وعنده وعي متطوّر
كوّن تنظيم سياسي
وبعدها دخل طلب من بعض أعضاء التنظيم السياسي
يدخلوا الجيش
أنا لا أقول هو انقلاب عسكري فحسب، هذا قصر نظر
«القذافي» حسب ما نعرف الآن
كون تنظيم سياسي في سبها
في ثانوية سبها، اللي درست فيها فيما بعد إعدادية وثانوية
ولأن النظام في هذاك الوقت يده لم تكن شرسة
وللا عنيفة في قمع المعارضين
فسمح له بالانتقال إلى مصراتة بعد مظاهرة في سبها سنة 1958
وحسب ما قال في خطاباته العديدة، وبعض زملائه
قرروا أن التركيز على الانضمام للجيش، وقلب نظام الحكم
وكان مثاله الأكبر، هو الرئيس «عبد الناصر»
هُزم في حرب 1948 في الفالوجة، حُصر
وبدأ ينظر إلى الفساد، والمشاكل الموجودة في مصر
وبدأ التفكير في قلب نظام الحكم
هذا أعطى «القذافي» فكرة أن طالب وناشط سياسي
قومي عربي إلى أنه هو يركز على
النظام الملكي كان شوية
كان أكثر من محاولة في الجيش الليبي
ولكن يبدو أن كان واهٍ، ولم يكن يعي بخطورة
أنه مجرد فروخ، وللا صايعين هذول شباب متطرفين
وراح ينتهي الموضوع
وفي هناك مقولات أخرى لم أجد دليل عنها
يقول أن مثلًا المرحوم الدكتور «محمود جبريل الورفلي»
في أطروحة الدكتوراة مهمة جدًّا
يقول: أن الأمريكان بطريقه غير مباشرة، وهذا لم يُكشف عنها
الآن في الأرشيف الأمريكي
عرفوا أن النظام بدأ يتآكل
وأن الشباب الليبي اللي هم تعلمون في المؤسسات التعليمية
صاروا متطرفين مدرسين مصريين وفلسطينيين وغيره
وبدأت مقولات صوت العرب والمنطقة والجزائر
كلها بدأت في تجدير التفكير القومي العربي
وهو مش في ليبيا بس، في المنطقة العربيّة كُل
لكن ليبيا جارها من ناحية الجزائر، ومن الجهة هنا مصر
فالتأثير كان قوي جدًّا
ومؤسسات الجيش كانت مفتوحة للقوى المعارضة
فاللي صار أعتقد أن هناك جدل، يقول: أن الحكومة الأمريكيّة
غضّت الطرف، عرفت أن النظام الآن بدأ يتآكل
وكان في فساد، مش بالفساد اللي هو موجود الآن
اللي هو الآن زي ما قال: يا «غسان»
الأستاذ اللبناني اللي كان مبعوث لليبيا «غسان»
اسمه إيه يا ربي
الدكتور «غسان سلامة»
قال: اللي صار في ليبيا مش فساد، في نهب
فقصدي أنه كانت موجودة هذه
في مقولات بتقول، أنا أحتاج أني أتحقق من هذا
والدكتور «محمود جبريل» أشار لها
أن في الأول لأن «القذافي» كان معادي جدًّا للشيوعيّة
وكثير من اليساريين الليبيين حطوهم في السجون، البعثيين والشيوعيين
أنه غضوا الطرف، طالما أنهم معادين للسعودية، ولما لا؟
فهمت نقطتي يا عبدالرحمن؟
أن ممكن هذا بطريق غير مباشر قبلوا بتغيير نظام الحكم
وخاصة في البدايات كان شديد العداء للشيوعية والاتحاد السوفييتي
هذه الطروحات والتفسيرات تحتاج تدقيق أكثر
لأن حتى الآن لا نملك أي دراسة معمقة وحصيفة
على هذه المواضيع الشائكة
ولكن للإنصاف النظام برغم قمعه للطلاب والمعارضين
حتى نهاية السبعينيات برغم كل العنف اللي صار
التخلص من القواعد الأجنبية
توسيع دائرة التعليم أكثر حتى من العهد الملكي
التأكيد على العُروبة والإسلام، وتأييد القضية الفلسطينية
لم يخلقها «القذافي» يا عبدالرحمن
هذه موجودة ومتجذّرة في الشعب الليبي
«القذافي» مجرد هو عبر عنها بعد فترة طويلة
ولكن للأسف الشديد الثمانينيات والتسعينيات صارت الموضوع أكثر
صارت دكتاتورية، وعبادة بطل واستبداد
اللي هو في نهاية الأمر خلّى حتى نظام «القذافي»
هذا اللي هو كان في جوانب إيجابية للمرآة وللمجتمع
والفئات المهمشة والفقيرة وغيرها
في الأخير بدأت تتآكل، والنظام لم يستطع تجديد ذاته، وإصلاحها
وهذا جاء بالنهاية على رأسه
فأنا أتمنى أن الليبيين
أن ينظروا بالجوانب المتعددة لجيل الاستقلال
وحتى، هو الآن مش مستعدين يعملوها
لكن نقول حتى لسبتمبر، نحتاج أن ننظر لها بهدوء
ونقول ما لها وما عليها، وهذا يؤدي إلى كثير من التصالح
لأن هناك شرائح من الشعب الليبي
ما زالت تعتقد أن «القذافي» ونظام سبتمبر
هو نظام مميز، واللي جاءنا من النيتو هو المشكلة
ودمروا ليبيا وغيره
وأنا أعتقد نبذ فكرة الانتقام
انتقام نظام سبتمبر، لأنه هو سود سمعة النظام الملكي
أو الانتقام من نخبة سبتمبر
أو الانتقام من الناس اللي هم كانوا في اللجان الثورية وغيره
الانتقام لا يبني الأمم والمجتمعات
لكن الاعتراف بشرعية الاختلاف
الاعتراف بتعدد السرديات وبالتنوع الثقافي والاجتماعي والفكري
هذا هو اللي راح يبني أمم ومجتمعات
وللأسف الشديد الصورة قاتمة الآن، يا عبدالرحمن
لكن لا يعني أن نفقد الأمل
الله يعين كل أهلنا في ليبيا
وإن شاء الله، يكون مستقبل أفضل يارب
إن شاء الله
شكرًا جزيلًا
كثير جزيلًا عبدالرحمن
شكرًا لكم
شكرًا لأيمن الحمّادي في إعداد الحلقة
في التحرير: محمد نور شمت
التصوير: آدم الشعراني
الهندسة الصوتية: محمد الحسن
التلوين: عبد المجيد العطاس
وإدارة الإنتاج: أصيل بافرط
إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي: نورة السبيعي
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحُب، من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل، ألقاكم
الحين بس أنا عندي سؤال من أول في بالي
تفضل
يوم غيّروا إيطاليا اسم ليبيا
كيف تقبّل أهل ليبيا؟
وكيف صار الآن الاسم الطبيعي؟
هذا سؤال لم يسألني عليه أي أحد
الطليان بدأوا، لما درت تحقيق في هذا الموضوع
اكتشفت أن في 1905 بدأوا يستخدموا ليبيا
لأسباب استعمارية، وهو أن احنا، هذا الاسم الروماني لليبيا
وهم بحاولوا يحطموا التركة العُثمانيّة
الدولة الإسلاميّة العُثمانيّة
تفهمني؟
وصاروا في أدبياتهم يقولون «ليبيا»
ولكن في سنة 1933
أعلنوا أن هذه ليبيا وموحدة الأقاليم الثلاثة، واسمها ليبيا
كدول مستعمرّة أخرى، حتى العراق لم يكن اسمها العراق
كانت ولايات عُثمانيّة
وسوريا الكبرى، جبل لبنان، صار دولة لبنان
وما كان في «إسرائيل»، كان فيه؟
وبذلك اللي صار أن الناس صار الاسم
المحافل الدولية تقولها
الليبيين اللي عاشوا الفترة الاستعمارية يقولوها
وصارت متقبّلة أن اسمها ليبيا
لكن أنا دائمًا أصر أقول: من الناحية الموضوعية التاريخية
اسم ليبيا حديث
الليبيين يزعلوا مني كثير، يا عبدالرحمن
معلومة صادمة، أول مرّة أسمعها
لأنك أنت ضحية كالآخرين، هذا المُشاع والمعتاد
في وحدة من المحضارات حضرتها، كنت أنت ذكرتها بشكل سريع
بس ما أدري قلت يمكن
فكأنك وصفت شمال إفريقيا بشكل مختلف عن الشرق الأوسط
فهل منطقي اليوم لما نسمع مصطلح
الشرق الأوسط وشمال إفريقيا
لأن فعلًا شمال إفريقيا يختلف عن الشرق الأوسط؟
لا
وللا هوياتيًا أو سياسًا؟
لا، أنا اعتقد أن، أنا ما أحب اسم الشرق الأوسط، بكل صراحة
هذا اسم أوربي وغربي
الشرق الأوسط لمن؟ لهم هم، لكن مش لنا احنا
احنا عالم عربي وإسلامي
وعندنا المشرق والمغرب
وبذلك أنا بالنسبة لي استخدام الألفاظ واللغة
مُهم بقدر تحليل المعلومات والمنطلقات
مرات نصير نكرر فيها وكأنها هي أشياء مسلّم بها
وصارت حقيقة، وهذا في كل كتاباتي تجده
بس احنا تنوّع تجاربنا العربيّة، حتى داخل لما تشوف السعودية
تجربة عسير ونجد والحجاز
كيف تكوّن هذا الكيان الموحد
هذا يحتاج نوع من الهدوء والإنصات والإنصاف
أيضًا عرب ومسلمي شمال أفريقيا، وأمازيغها
جاهدوا ضد الاستعمار الأوربي
وفي ليبيا تحديدًا معركة كانت مهمة، وهي ضد الاستعمار الأوربي
وبذلك لم يكن هناك «الشريف حسين»
وقضية هذا الجاسوس البريطاني المستشرق
اللي عملوه عَلَم، هذا لم يكن موجود، النضال
«لورنس» تقصد؟
«لورنس العرب» بالضبط
ولهذا إخوتنا في المشرق، وبالذات في الشام
كانوا يركزوا على مسألة في النضال ضد الأتراك والعثمانيين
هذه الإشكالية مش موجودة في شمال إفريقيا، يا عبدالرحمن
وتحديدًا في ليبيا
لأن ينظروا للعثمانيين حاربوا معاهم، وهم مسلمين
في النهاية الأمر، احنا كلنا مسلمين
وكثير من الباحثين العرب يقفزوا على هذا التنوع التاريخي
وهذا يدل على كسل فكري
مش هذا أفضل من هذا، وللا شيء
بس نفهم تنوّع تركيبتنا وتحولاتنا
وهذا يساعدنا أن نتعامل معها بشكل أكثر وضوحًا وجديةً
آخر حاجة، أنا طوّلت عليك
تفضل
في كأس العالم
نتكلم لأن المغرب مشاركة، وأدّت أداء باهر
فتسمع في بعض لقاءات المغربيين والمغاربة
فكانوا يقولون: أن هذا الفوز لإفريقيا، ومدري كيف وزي كذا
وبس كنت أتساءل
هل لو فازت السعودية، هل بقول أن هذا الفوز لآسيا؟
علاقتنا بآسيا علاقة ما هي
لا
ما لها أي علاقة، احنا أقدر أقول مسلمين وعرب
أقدر أقول سعوديين أو جزائريين، اللي تبغى
هل منطقي، في بعضهم يقول لك: أنا ماني بعربي، أنا إفريقي
كيف تشوف هذه؟
أنا أجد أن هذا، أنا جاوبت عليه في الكتاب
وإذا كان ما عندك، أرسله لك
اللي هو «ما بعد الاستعمار والقومية»
وطرحت هذا السؤال اللي حضرتك تطرحه
هذا توظيف سياسي للهويات
شمال إفريقيا منطقة المغرب العربي الإسلامي بشكل عام
هي في إفريقيا
وأنا دائمًا أقول: بدل ما نقول احنا عرب، وللا أفارقة
زي «القذافي» في الأخير دارها بشكل
احنا عرب ومسلمين وأفارقة
احنا الناس اللي جينا من الجزيرة العربيّة
والأماكن الأخرى واليمن وغيرها
واحتكينا وامتزجنا مع السكان الأصليين اللي هم البربر والأمازيغ
ولكن أيضًا امتزجنا مع الأفارقة الآخرين
ثقافيًّا وعائليًّا وفكريًّا وفقهيًّا
وبذلك بدل ما تقول: احنا أفارقة، وللا كذا
هذا أعتقد نوع من التوظيف السياسي لأغراض آنيّة
لكن احنا يجب أن نتوقف، ونقول: احنا عرب ومسلمين وأفارقة
ومن الجزيرة والشام، وبعض منّا يطل على البحر المتوسط
وهذه كلها مستويات متعددة لهوية واحدة
الهوية بعبارة أخرى، دائمًا أحاجج ليست ذات وجه واحد
الهوية متعددة الأوجه
أنت مثلًا سعودي، ومن عسير، وتعيش في الرياض
والآن في نيويورك، ودرست في أريزونا
وهذه كلها الأشياء مع بعضها
قصدي أن آن الأوان أن بدر التوظيف السياسي
أن نعترف أننا متعدّدي الأوجه
وهذا لا يقلل من حالتنا، وللا شيء
هذا لأن تركيبتنا لها تأثيرات متعدّدة
والتعريف العربي والإسلامي الآن ليس بتعريف عرقي
ولكن تعريف متراكب ومترابط ومتشابك